[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer
einigkeit
und Recht
und Freiheit nicht zum ersten Mal
zitiere ich hier unsere Hymne denn das
alte Lied der deutschen beschreibt noch
immer Werte die auch für die moderne
liberale Demokratie unersetzlich sind
und diese Werte sind einer schlimmen
Kraftprobe ausgesetzt
Putin hat ihnen in der Ukraine
militärisch den Kampf angesagt und seit
dieser Woche wissen wir dass Putin der
Einigkeit
dem Recht und der Freiheit Deutschlands
den wirtschaftlichen Kampf angesagt hat
den Putins Regierung hat nun auch
offiziell die Energielieferungen zum
politischen Kampfinstrument erklärt die
Bundesregierung ist sich bewusst dass
diese Kampfansage mit schweren
Belastungen für viele Menschen und
Betriebe in unserem Land verbunden ist
wir werden nicht jede dieser Belastungen
ausgleichen können
aber die Tatsache dass wir mit den drei
entlastungspaketen mittlerweile fast 100
Milliarden Euro mobilisiert haben um zu
helfen zeigt dass uns die soziale
Einheit unseres Landes viel wert ist
meine Damen und Herren
und Freiheit sind die Hauptaufgaben
meines Hauses viele Beobachter konnten
erkennen dass wir hier bereits große
Anstrengungen unternommen haben der
Staatsrechtler Oliver Lepsius erklärte
jüngst in der Tageszeitung Die Welt das
etwa die corona-politik mit dem
Regierungswechsel deutlich transparenter
verhältnismäßiger und stärker an den
Grundrechten orientiert erfolgen würde
das ist ein Fortschritt bei Recht und
Freiheit meine Damen und Herren
die Süddeutsche Zeitung
schrieb vor einigen Wochen über die
vielen Initiativen im Bereich der
Familiengesellschaft oder auch
strafrechtspolitik dass man eben in der
Rechtspolitik Zitat den
gesellschaftspolitischen zaunt Zitat
Ende der neuen Regierung deutlich
mitpräge ich glaube das ist ein
Fortschritt bei Recht und Freiheit meine
Damen und
als erstes Haus hat das
Bundesministerium der Justiz einen
Gesetzentwurf zur planungsbeschleunigung
vorgelegt mit einer Reform der
Verwaltungsgerichtsordnung leisten wir
unseren Beitrag dass es jetzt mit den
wichtigen Großprojekten bei den
Verwaltungsgerichten schneller vorangeht
das ist ein Fortschritt im Recht und
angesichts der Bedeutung einer neuen
Energieinfrastruktur die uns unabhängig
von Putin macht auch ein Beitrag zur
Freiheit meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren
wir erledigen diese Aufgaben sehr
kostengünstig denn für diesen Entwurf
des Einzelplans meines Hauses gilt wir
geben weniger als eine Milliarde Euro
aus und wir erwirtschaften fast 70
Prozent davon durch eigene Einnahmen das
ist ein kostennutzenverhältnis glaube
ich dass ich sehen kann meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
die Summe der Ausgaben ist klein
trotzdem ist die Sorgfalt im Umgang mit
dem Steuerzahlergeld gleichwohl groß das
hat uns übrigens der Bundesrechnungshof
bestätigt in diesem Jahr gab es zum
Entwurf des Einzelplans 7 keine einzige
Beanstandung und auch das ist eine gute
Nachricht meine Damen und Herren
trotzdem haben wir gestalterische und
politische Schwerpunkte gesetzt die sich
auch in diesem Entwurf niederschlagen
die Finanzierung der
überwachungsgesamtrechnung ist geregelt
die Stiftung Datenschutz hat wieder eine
Perspektive um besser arbeiten zu können
und auch die weitere Digitalisierung der
Justiz ist sichergestellt wir entwickeln
gemeinsam mit den Ländern und dem
Bundesgerichten ein bundeseinheitliches
System für videoverhandlungen wir haben
begonnen ein zivilgerichtliches
Online-Verfahren zu entwickeln und wir
arbeiten an einer digitalen
Rechtsantragsstelle für die digitale
Erfassung von Anliegen und Anträgen bei
Gerichten auch für die Justiz gilt also
wir wollen mehr Fortschritt wagen
ansonsten werden wir rechtspolitisch
auch nicht müde wir werden bald endlich
und das sage ich ausgegebenem Anlass an
dieser Stelle die anlasslose
Vorratsdatenspeicherung beenden endlich
meine Damen und Herren
und wir werden in der Gesellschaft
soffrecht Stichwort Halbierung der
Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe im Namensrecht und
vor allem im Familienrecht auch in den
kommenden Monaten daran arbeiten das
Recht endlich auf die Höhe der
gesellschaftlichen Wirklichkeit zu
bringen
das stärkt im übrigen auch die Justiz
der Länder
denn die Länder werden allein durch die
Reform der Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe
voraussichtlich über 60 Millionen Euro
im Jahr sparen auf den Zeitraum einer
Legislaturperiode gerechnet ist das
übrigens mehr als der alte Pakt für den
Rechtsstaat bewegt hat und es ist vor
allen Dingen eine Entlastung die für
immer bleibt keine Anschubfinanzierung
sei Entlastung die für immer bleibt und
ich gehe natürlich davon aus dass jeder
gesparte Euro im System der Justiz
verbleibt und
umher auch dieses Thema zu erwähnen
natürlich bleibt meine Hand weiter
ausgestreckt
um mit den Ländern über die
Ausgestaltung einer weiteren Förderung
der landesjustiz aus Mitteln des Bundes
zu sprechen das tun wir auf Arbeitsebene
übrigens schon seit März diesen Jahres
und egal worauf wir uns einigen eines
ist mir dabei wichtig es Geld muss
zusätzlich investiert werden es muss in
der Justiz bleiben und es muss dazu
beitragen dass wir eine modernere
digitale Justiz bekommen meine Damen und
Herren ich komme zum Schluss
einigkeit und Recht und Freiheit das ist
unser Leitstern in dunkler Zeit dem
führen wir uns verpflichtet und dem
dient dieser Haushaltsentwurf ich freue
mich auf konstruktive Beratungen darüber
wie gesagt
hier zum Auftakt der Beratungen seines
Etat er hat auch zu einigen aktuellen
noch Hinweise gegeben beispielsweise
Stichwort Pakt für den Rechtsstaat seit
Monaten drängen die Bundesländer auf
Geld vom Bund für mehr Personal in der
Justiz des Spitzen treffen das soll nun
den Durchbruch bringen und ist für den
16 September hier in Berlin geplant sehr
geehrter der Bundesminister sehr geehrte
Damen und Herren liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Haushalt des Bundes
Justizministeriums ist es der kleinste
Einzelplan aber er ist nicht minder
wichtig denn das Justizministerium ist
auch der Garant für den Schutz unseres
Rechtsstaates und unserer Grundrechte
die Gesamtausgaben für 2023 sind
angesetzt mit ca 954 Millionen Euro und
das sind 15,4 Millionen Euro oder 1,6
Prozent mehr als in diesem Jahr
ein besonderer Einsatz des
Justizministers für diesen Haushalt
lässt sich allerdings mit den Zahlen
nicht verbinden
sie haben zwar unsere Kritik an der
Personalausstattung des
generalbundesanwaltes aufgegriffen und
haben die Mittelkürzung aus 2022 in 2023
wieder rückgängig gemacht
aberem Haushalt fehlen die Mittel für
ein digitalpakt es fehlen die Mittel für
die Fortsetzung des Paktes für den
Rechtsstaat und die Inflation die in
diesem Jahr mit acht Prozent anschlägt
im nächsten Jahr mit 8% zuschlägt ist im
Haushalt nicht berücksichtigt das heißt
der Etat
sinkt in allen Ansätzen faktisch und das
ist gerade in diesen Zeiten ein Fehler
das gilt im übrigen auch für die
Stiftungen die unterstützt werden ebenso
wie die Tatsache dass auch möglich beim
personalen mögliche Erhöhungen nicht
berücksichtigt sind sie haben sich für
den für das Gesetz zur
planbeschleunigung gelobt ja das ist gut
dass wir hier ein Beschleunigungsgesetz
auf den Weg gebracht haben oder dass sie
es auf den Weg gebracht haben aber wo
sie keinen Schritt vorangekommen sind
und was nicht minder wichtig ist ist der
Pakt für den Rechtsstaat und der
digitalpakt die FDP lieber Herr Kollege
Buschmann bezeichnet sich ja gerne als
digital Polizei aber leider haben sie
hier in diesem Bereich in der Zeit seit
sie diese Ministerium vorstehen mit den
Ländern keine einzige Lösung und keinen
einzigen Fortschritt herbeigeführt es
reicht nicht aus sich mit den Ländern
nur auszutauschen sie befinden sich mit
den Ländern und allen Fraktionen in
einer
dauerauseinandersetzung und deshalb
steht nächste Woche auch der nächste
Krisengipfel an und beim Thema
Digitalisierung liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen von der FDP lieber Herr
Buschmann kann man hier wahrlich nicht
von einem Fortschritt sprechen sie haben
es nicht geschafft ein
digitalministerium in dieser Ampel
durchzusetzen und sie haben es bis jetzt
nicht mehr geschafft als ein
Eckpunktepapier zur Digitalisierung
vorzulegen Ende August ist erstmal
nichts anderes enthält als
Zuständigkeiten zu beschreiben
die FDP liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
bezeichnet sich eben auch gerne als
rechtsstaatspartei der Rechtsstaat der
existiert aber nicht einfach so die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger die Länder sie
müssen darauf vertrauen können dass er
funktioniert und das gemachte Zusagen
eingehalten werden
gemachte Zusagen müssen eingehalten
werden dafür braucht man um diese Rechte
durchsetzen zu können genügend Personal
und die Länder fordern daher auch zu
Recht dass der in der letzten
Legislaturperiode vereinbarte und
erfolgreiche Pakt für den Rechtsstaat
als Pakt für den Rechtsstaat zwei Punkt
Null auch wie versprochen weitergeführt
wird es muss immer noch in Deutschland
im Schnitt ein dringend ein dringend
Tatverdächtiger pro Woche aus der
Untersuchungshaft entlassen werden weil
die Gerichte überlastet und die
Strafverfahren zu lange dauern das nach
darf nicht sein wir haben das in der
letzten Legislaturperiode angepackt
gemeinsam mit den Ländern sie haben im
Koalitionsvertrag versprochen es
fortzusetzen und sie halten ihre
Versprechen schlicht und ergreifend
nicht ein
den Rechtsstaat liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen den digitalen Rechtsstaat den
gibt es nicht zum Nulltarif und deswegen
fordern wir Sie auch auf mit den Ländern
gemeinsam den Rechtsstaat zwei Punkt
Null vorzusetzen und einen digitalpakt
für die Justiz abzuschließen sie haben
ja nächste Woche beim Krisengipfel mit
den Ländern die Chance dazu
es ist aber nicht nur erforderlich dass
ausreichend finanzielle Mittel zur
Verfügung stehen wichtig sind auch
richtige thematische
Schwerpunktsetzungen mit vor allen
Dingen den richtigen Prioritäten hier
setzen sie oft auf die falschen
Prioritäten und das möchte ich Ihnen an
einem Punkt ganz gerne erläutern sie
haben mit wirklich großen Tamtam hier im
Haus im Frühjahr als erstes großes
Projekt das Verbot der Werbung für
Schwangerschaft ab
Schwangerschaftsabbrüche den Paragrafen
219a StGB abgeschafft sie haben sich
dafür auf die Schulter geklopft
besser wäre es aber gewesen sie hätten
einen Vorschlag zur Speicherung von
IP-Adressen vorgelegt um die fast 14
Millionen Kinder und Jugendlichen in
Deutschland besser vor sexueller Gewalt
und Kinderpornografie zu schützen allein
schon an ihren Zwischenrufen lässt sich
erkennen wie wenig wichtig Ihnen dieses
Thema ist leider
[Applaus]
nämlich oft der einzige Hinweis
auf die Täter und das wird ihnen jeder
Ermittler bestätigen der EuGH hat die
Speicherung schon im Oktober 2020 für
zulässig erklärt und Liebe SPD ihre
Innenministerin hat es mittlerweile auch
verstanden und sie ist auch dafür was
den Betroffenen aber nichts nützt ist
die Uneinigkeit der Ampel die
Uneinigkeit zwischen Herrn Buschmann und
Frau Feser deshalb Herr Buschmann
verabschieden sie sich endlich von ihrer
placebulösung wie quick crease und
handeln sie endlich im Interesse der
Kinder
und auch beim Vorschlag der Europäischen
Kommission einer Verordnung zur
Verhinderung und Bekämpfung von
sexuellen Kindesmissbrauch lassen sie
wahrlich jedes positive Engagement
vermissen man muss nicht mit allem
einverstanden sein was die Kommission so
vorschlägt aber dass man von ihnen
wieder nur Skepsis und Ablehnung
vernimmt
natürlich dürfen digitale Bürgerrechte
keine Rechte zweiter Klasse sein aber es
reicht nun mal für einen Justizminister
nicht aus hier allgemein Bedenken zu
äußern es geht darum sich aktiv Gedanken
zu machen und Lösungen zu finden wie man
Kinderpornografie in sozialen Netzwerken
und auf Plattformen besser bekämpft wie
man mit klaren Rechtsgrundlagen mit
verbindlichen meldewegen und einem neuen
eu-zentrum Prävention und
Strafverfolgung zum Beispiel bei bereits
bekannten kinderpornografischen Bildern
ermöglicht und ich sage Ihnen in diesem
Haus eins die Schwächsten in unserer
Gesellschaft unsere Kinder vor diesem
widerlichen Verbrechen zu schützen auch
und gerade im digitalen Bereich das muss
unsere Aufgabe sein das muss uns eine
vordringliche Aufgabe sein
gestatten Sie mir zu guter Letzt auch
noch eine abschließende Bemerkung zu den
heute beschlossenen Änderungen des
Infektionsschutzgesetzes
sie haben sich ja immer so für ihre
fortschrittliche Politik gerühmt gerade
auch im Digitalbereich sie haben es aber
verpasst in den letzten Monaten die
Chance für eine fortschrittliche die
Chance an einer fortschriftlichen
pandemiepolitik mitzuarbeiten und
wirkliche Weichen zu stellen statt sich
öffentlich mit dem Gesundheitsminister
pausenlos zu streiten hätten sie besser
dass von uns geforderte impfregister auf
den Weg gebracht das würde uns nämlich
heute in dieser Zeit und in Zukunft
ermöglichen die Pandemie besser zu
managen das würde uns ermöglichen unsere
Bürger besser zu schützen und es würde
uns auch ermöglichen die Grundrechte
besser zu schützen
lieber Herr buschmann
es ist jetzt knapp ein Jahr her ein
Viertel der Legislaturperiode ist vorbei
ich sage Ihnen wenn Sie wirklich etwas
für den Rechtsstaat in unserem Land tun
wollen dann fangen Sie endlich an
richtig zu handeln und bessern sie vor
allen Dingen noch beim Haushalten nach
vielen Dank
erfordert hier Andrea Lindholz für die
cdu/csu-fraktion ist die
stellvertretende
Fraktionsvorsitzende und eine nachklappe
zu den corona-regeln gab es auch noch
die hat der Bundestag ja gerade heute
beschlossen für Herbst und Winter
und Marco Buschmann hatte die ja mit
seinem Kabinettskollegen Karl Lauterbach
zusammen verhandelt
ein Kollegen verehrte Zuhörerinnen und
Zuhörer diese Haushaltsberatung stehen
mehr denn je unter dem Zeichen des
Sparens der Einhaltung der
Schuldenbremse und dem Ringen um die
Maßnahmen und Projekte die jetzt gerade
in einer Zeit mit diversen
haus-herausforderungen parallel Corona
Ukraine Krieg Lieferengpässen Inflation
steigenden Energie und
Lebenshaltungskosten von herausragender
Bedeutung sind für die Menschen in
unserem Land Theodor Fontane wird das
Zitat zugeschrieben eine richtige
Sparsamkeit vergisst nie das nicht immer
gespart werden kann wer immer sparen
will der ist verloren auch moralisch
für uns Sozialdemokraten gilt die
Erkenntnis dass investieren in der Krise
uns vor hohen Folgekosten bewahrt die
dadurch entstünden wenn wir jetzt in der
Krise nämlich nichts täten nur um keine
neuen Schulden zu machen ja wir sind
bereit zu sparen aber bitte nicht kaputt
sparen liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
deshalb müssen wir alle Möglichkeiten in
diesem Haushalt ausschöpfen um das Geld
was zur Verfügung steht dort
zielgerichtet einzusetzen wo es jetzt am
dringendsten gebraucht wird für den
Einzelplan 07 Justiz haben wir am Montag
bereits unser berichterstattergespräch
durchgeführt danke an den
hauptberichterstatter und das
Ministerium für die Organisation die
Durchführung und insbesondere für die
Beantwortung unserer Fragen und die
Erläuterung zu den haushaltstiteln im
justizhaushalt Frau Lindhorst sie haben
es gerade gesagt sind 953 Millionen sie
haben gesagt 4954 das ist ein
quetschbetrag Dazwischen Euro
eingestellt insgesamt verzeichnet dieser
Einzelplan einen geringen aufwuchs der
zum einen mit höheren Ausgaben im
Personalbereich zusammenhängt
insbesondere durch höhere Zuweisungen an
den Versorgungsfonds aber auch für
Aufträge und Dienstleistungen im Bereich
Informationstechnik von 70.000 Euro im
2022 auf immerhin 4 Millionen
995.000 Euro im Jahr 2023 für den Aufbau
von datenlaboren und dieser Schwerpunkt
des Justizministers auf Digitalisierung
zeigt sich auch bei Maßnahmen im Bereich
des Ministeriums selbst in dem Mittel in
Höhe von 3 Millionen eingeplant sind
wichtig um den Bürgerinnen und Bürgern
den Zugang zum Recht zu erleichtern und
Barrieren abzubauen
bedauerlicherweise das ist unser
Wermutstropfen kommen aber die Belange
im Kampf gegen Extremismus Hass und
Hetze im Netz Gewalt gegenüber
Minderheiten wie zuletzt in Münster im
Rahmen des CSD und die Beratung von
Ehrenamtlichen Kommunalpolitikerinnen
und Kommunalpolitikern bei digitalen
Angriffen noch zu kurz sehr effektive
Projektförderung laufen aus zum Beispiel
für
hate-lösung für Betroffene gibt
sicherlich wäre es auch unsere
Auffassung nach ein gutes Zeichen
gewesen im Hinblick auf die
Gedenkveranstaltung mit dem israelischen
Staatspräsidenten Herzog am Dienstag
dieser Woche und der
Ausstellungseröffnung im Paul-Löbe-Haus
auch in diesem Haushalt das
Wohnungsbauprojekt für Holocaust
Überlebende in Israel wieder mit einem
Betrag von 200.000 Euro zu unterstützen
wie wir es im parlamentarischen
Verfahren auch für den Haushalt 2022
erneut ausverhandelt haben
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen ein Thema
hat mich im Einzelplan 07 besonders
umgetrieben
seit der Gründung der stiftungforum
recht durch den Deutschen Bundestag im
Jahr 2019 beschäftigt uns das Thema
eigentlich in jeder Haushaltsdebatte die
Stiftung ist im aufwachsen und ich kann
von mir behaupten dass ich diese
Gründung auch persönlich
vorangetrieben habe und versucht habe
die beteiligten Akteure endlich einmal
zusammenzuführen und dass dieses Kind
des Parlaments gut gedeiht ist mir
weiterhin ein großes Anliegen diese
Woche waren auch die beiden Direktoren
der Stiftung vor Ort in Berlin zum
Gespräch bei mir und sicherlich auch bei
einigen von ihnen
um für die Aufstockung ihrer Mittel für
die Stiftung zu bitten warum erwähne ich
das liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen weil
ich Mitglied im Kuratorium bin und weil
ich als Haushälterin für das BMJ bei dem
die Stiftung angesiedelt ist mehrfach
beim Kuratorium auf die angespannte
Haushaltslage des Bundeshaushalts
hingewiesen und versucht habe die
Erwartungen zu dämpfen die Zuweisung an
die Stiftung würden mittelfristig auf
einen mittleren zweistelligen
Millionenbetrag anwachsen die Stiftung
erhält in diesem Haushalt denselben
Betrag wie in 2022 nämlich 3,5 Millionen
Euro mit hin aber 1,7 Millionen Euro
weniger als sie selbst in ihrer
Haushaltsplanung veranschlagt und im
Kuratorium beschlossen hat
auch der Beschluss des Kuratoriums dem
ich als Haushälterin nicht zustimmen
konnte ich zitiere einmal das Kuratorium
fordert den Haushaltsgesetzgeber auf den
erfüllungsaufwand der Stiftung Forum
recht in einem dem aufwuchs
auskömmlichen Maße vorzuschreiben kann
aber nicht dazu führen dass dann diese
Mittel auch zwangsläufig im
Bundeshaushalt eingestellt werden und
der Stiftung geht es in diesem Jahr
leider wie vielen anderen Projekten und
Vorhaben in allen anderen Einzelplänen
sie sind betroffen von den Sparmaßnahmen
die wir einhalten müssen umso mehr um im
sozialen Bereichen dringend benötigt das
Geld in die Hand nehmen zu können
alle reden über entlastungspakete Kritik
wird geäußert das haben wir heute ja
auch wieder gehört es sei zu wenig es
treffe zum Teil die falschen Adressaten
es sei nicht bedarfsgericht ich finde
die bisherigen entlastungspakete sehr
gut und umsichtig wenn jetzt auch die
Länder ihren Beitrag leisten kommen wir
noch mal einen guten Schritt voran zum
Beispiel mit einem Folgeangebot für das
9-euro-ticket
finanziell werden wir im Haushalt des
BMJ für entlastungspakete keine
hilfenleistung können aber erstens sie
haben es auch schon gesagt Herr Dr
Buschmann bauen und planen dauert zu
lange dadurch werden die Kosten kaum
noch kalkulierbar und hier kann das
Ministerium einen wichtigen Beitrag
leisten und Gesetze zur Planungs- und
genehmigungsbeschleunigung auf den Weg
bringen und eventuell mit dem
Bauministerium zusammen auch das
Baugesetzbuch novellieren Vorsorge im
Justizbereich wurde bereits getroffen
und ein neuer Senat beim
Bundesverwaltungsgericht geschaffen um
dann auch bei zusätzlichen
Klageverfahren diese schnell abarbeiten
zu können und dann nicht auf der
gerichtsebene die planungsbeschleunigung
wieder zu torpedieren
Herr Minister dr Buschmann und das
Ministerium kann auch sehr viel mehr zu
Entlastung der Bürgerinnen und Bürger
beitragen nicht mit Geld aber mit der
Umsetzung der Gesetzesvorhaben aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag zum Schutz von
Mieterinnen und Mietern und
mieterschutzregelungen verlängern die
kappungsgrenzen absenken die
mietpreisbremse verlängern qualifizierte
Mietspiegel rechtssicher ausgestalten
und Transparenz bei den
Nebenkostenabrechnungen schaffen Herr
Minister ich hoffe all das wird von
ihrer Vorhabenplanung für das zweite
Halbjahr auch noch umfasst sein auch
wenn es dort nur mit dem Stichwort
Mietrecht ohne nähere Ausführung in
ihren Plan aufgenommen wurde das wäre
eine echte Entlastung der Bürgerinnen
und Bürger ohne dass sie in ihrem
Haushalt auch nur einen Euro dafür
investieren müssten
zum Schluss möchte ich gerne noch mal
auf den Vorwurf eingehen im Ministerium
oder seitens des Ministers würde kein
Geld vorgesehen für den Pakt für den
Rechtsstaat oder für den digitalpakt ich
habe es eben auch schon dazwischen
gerufen wer das genau verfolgt hat und
wer sich mit Haushaltsrecht auskennt der
weiß dass für den Pakt für den
Rechtsstaat niemals Geld in dem
justizhaushalt gestanden hat es wird
über die umsatzsteuerpunkte geregelt das
kann auch nicht im bundesjustizhaushalt
Stehen und so ist es in der
Vergangenheit gemacht worden und ich
finde wenn die Steuereinnahmen der
Umsatzsteuer zwischen Bund und Ländern
aufgeteilt werden dann können auch die
Länder verdammt noch mal ihrer Pflicht
nachkommen sich an den finanziellen
Kosten für Ausgaben für länderaufgaben
zumindest beteiligen denn Justiz ist nun
mal länderaufgabe und ich finde schon
großartig wenn wir als Bund die Hand
ausstrecken und mit den Ländern
gemeinsam einen Pakt für den Rechtsstaat
ausgestalten und genau das wird auch im
digitalpakt so sein wir dürfen es aus
verfassungsrechtlichen Gründen gar nicht
in den justizhaushalt Schreiben und das
sollten wir und genau darum geht es wenn
sie uns vorwerfen es steht nicht drin es
kann eben auch nicht drin stehen lesen
Sie Ihre Rede noch mal nach bedanke mich
für Ihre Aufmerksamkeit
soweit es der dich ja für die SPD sie
ist Mitglied des Haushaltsausschusses so
auch der nächste Redner Michael Espen de
la für die afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kollegen liebe Zuschauer im Saal
und bei Youtube wenn es um die Lage der
Justiz und des Rechts in Deutschland
geht dann weiß man gar nicht wo man
anfangen und wo man aufhören soll denn
vieles davon ist einfach nur noch irre
wir befinden uns in einer
rechtspositivistischen Spirale in dem
die Produkte der Rechtssetzung dieses
Parlaments zunehmend willkürlich werden
und völlig entrückt sind von jeder Form
von Rationalität Zahlen Daten und Fakten
spielen scheinbar keine Rolle mehr
gerade vorhin haben wir hier über das
Infektionsschutzgesetz abgestimmt ein
Gesetz dass es schlicht und einfach
nicht braucht ein Gesetz dass die
Ampelkoalition in einer Phase
verabschiedet hat in der Corona längst
zu Endemie geworden ist während die
Regierung fast wahnhaft immer noch
versucht eine Pandemie herbeizureden
eine sogenannte Pandemie die wenn man
der Logik der Regierung folgt ihre Opfer
nicht in deutschen regierungsfliegern
befällt wohl aber in normalen
verkehrsfliegern im deutschen Luftraum
weswegen man bisher Maske tragen muss im
regierungsflieger eben nicht von der SPD
und den Grünen ist man ja einiges an
Irrationalität gewohnt doch von einer
Partei wie der FDP die sich noch immer
als rechtsstaatspartei bezeichnet hätte
man mehr erwartet
doch dieses Label hat sich als Etiketten
Schwindel entpuppt denn der
fdp-justizminister ist nicht in der Lage
oder nicht willens diesen Begriff auch
tatsächlich mit Leben zu füllen und das
ist überhaupt und im Allgemeinen die
ganze Krux bei der Sache nachdem man in
Zeiten der Aufklärung herausgearbeitet
hat dass Exekutive Judikative und die
Legislative niemals in einer Hand
vereint sein sollen haben wir in
Deutschland ein absolut vorbildliches
System der Gewaltenteilung gearbeitet
erkämpft und eingerichtet schön dass Sie
da lachen ergänzt wird dieses System von
der sogenannten vierten Gewalt freie
Medien die der Theorie nach alle anderen
drei Gewalten kontrollieren sollen
dieses System steht und es sieht gut aus
und doch drängt sich bei immer mehr
Menschen der Gedanke auf dass es
vielleicht bald nur noch eine leere
Hülle ist dass die Gewaltenteilung zwar
auf dem Papier existiert aber eben nicht
mehr gelebt wird beispielsweise dann
wenn die Vertreter der vierten Gewalt
mit im regierungsflieger Sitzen selbst
gegen Recht und gesetzverstoßen indem
sie dort eben keine Mast getragen und
diese Berechtigung
zwischenfragezeichen
so diesen Rechtsverstoß dann auch in
trotzigen Leitartikeln verteidigen statt
sich in Demut zu üben vom
Bundesjustizminister übrigens kein Wort
zu diesem zweiklassenrecht klar nach der
öffentlichen Empörung will man jetzt die
maskenpflicht in Flugzeug abschaffen
obwohl auch deshalb weil das staatliche
Gewaltmonopol hier droht das Gesicht zu
verlieren die maskenpflicht im deutschen
Luftraum ist ein internationaler Exot
und längst nicht mehr durchsetzbar aber
der Minister hält fest an der
maskenpflicht im Zug an der Möglichkeit
zu demonstrationsverboten
ausgangssperrungen Schulschließungen und
neuen lockdowns und das obwohl Herr Dr
Buschmann uns allen doch das absolute
Ende dieser Maßnahmen versprochen hatte
Maßnahmen die schon im letzten und auch
im vorletzten Jahr von der Wissenschaft
als in großen Teilen unsinnig bewertet
wurden ich weiß Politiker setzen häufig
darauf dass die Menschen schnell
vergessen aber wir alle haben doch die
Bilder im Kopf Polizisten die im Winter
schlittenfahrenden Kindern hinterher
jagen das hat sich in das kollektive
Gedächtnis dieser Nation für immer
eingebrannt ebenso wie die oft rabiate
Auflösung von Demonstration gegen
corona-politik weil dort im Freien keine
Maske getragen wurde während sich das
Gewaltmonopol daran bei Demonstrationen
unter dem Banner der Friday for Futures
Schulschwänzer nicht störte Resultat
solcher exekutivleistungen und
rechtsetzungsakten wie dem
Infektionsschutzgesetz ist dass nicht
nur das Vertrauen in den Rechtsstaat
sinkt sondern dass in die
Leistungsfähigkeit des Staates selbst
laut einer aktuellen Umfrage des vorsah
von Forsa im Auftrag der dbb sind nur
noch 29 Prozent der Bundesbürger aktuell
der Meinung dass der Staat in der Lage
ist seine Aufgaben zu erfüllen und das
sollte uns alle aufrütteln und ganz
besonders auch den Justizminister denn
das Bundesjustizministerium wirkt zwar
Aufgabenbeschreibung bei allen Gesetzen
ordnungsentwurf an anderer
Bundesministerien mit ich komme zum
Schulschluss und in diesem Zusammenhang
sollte sich auch ein Justizminister
dafür stark machen dass das Wort Evidenz
nicht zum Fremdwort in unserer
Rechtssetzung wird herzlichen dank
Michael Espen adilla war das und ob nun
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin eine
Kurzintervention zulässt das liegt in
ihrem Ermessen
nein also geht es weiter mit der
Rednerliste Bruno hünne spricht
sie haben jetzt viel geredet nix zum
Haushalt gesagt sie haben offensichtlich
nur zu YouTube tatsächlich geredet mein
kollegete steffen hat gerade gesagt er
glaubt nicht dass das viral geht ich
kann mich da nur anschließen
sehr geehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sie wissen der
Einzelplan 7 der Etat des BMJ ist ein
personalgeprägter Verwaltungshaushalt
die Ausgaben sind stabil unter einer
Milliarde das notwendige im
Zuständigkeitsbereich des BMJ wird
finanziert und die Einnahmen decken die
Ausgaben zu zwei Dritteln auf stabilen
Niveau für den Haushälter ist das
tatsächlich sehr sehr erfreulich und
auch bei genauerer Betrachtung kann
festgehalten werden dass der vorliegende
Entwurf grundsolide ist so hat es ja
auch der Bundesrechnungshof bestätigt
und auch wenn das alles recht
unspektakulär klingt die Herausforderung
für unseren Rechtsstaat die sind
natürlich riesig in einer globalisierten
Welt wird auch die Frage von Recht und
Gerechtigkeit komplexer die
Justizbehörden und Gerichte sind den
Anforderungen unserer krisenbehaften
Zeit ausgesetzt und auch sie müssen mit
der Zeit gehen wenn die corona-pandemie
uns eines gezeigt hat dann ist es doch
dass wir in der Digitalisierung massiv
hinterher hängen noch immer werden
Schrift zu Haus online verschickt nur um
dann bei Gericht wieder ausgedruckt und
wieder eingescannt zu werden es ist also
kein Wunder dass Deutschland im
eu-justizbarometer 2021 bei der
Digitalisierung nur Mittelfeld gelangt
ist das bedeutet für uns der digitalpakt
für den Rechtsstaat den wir im
Koalitionsvertrag verankert haben muss
hier liefern wir stehen gemeinsam mit
den Ländern in der Verantwortung für
eine Justiz auf der Höhe der Zeit
wichtig wichtig ist also dass wir das
Ding jetzt zielgenau aufs Gleis setzen
der Minister hat seine Bereitschaft auch
in Finanzierungsfragen hier bekundet wir
nehmen sie da beim Lord lieber Minister
Marco Buschmann mit Blick auf die
Stellenpläne möchte ich zwei sehr
positive Entwicklungen herausstellen
die alle wissen der völkerrechtswidrige
russische Angriffskrieg gegen die
Ukraine dauert an Monate der Brutalität
Monate der Zerstörung und der Massaker
an der Zivilbevölkerung deswegen ist es
essentiell dass der Generalbundesanwalt
gut ausgestattet ist gerade im Bereich
der internationalen Kooperation wir
wollen und wir müssen unseren Beitrag
leisten damit die grolltaten aufgeklärt
werden dafür haben wir im 22er Haushalt
den Generalbundesanwalt besser
ausgestattet und das setzen wir nun fort
wir sorgen also dafür dass Täter zur
Rechenschaft gezogen werden können es
darf und es wird keine Blaupause für
Kriegsverbrechen geben nicht im Inland
nicht im Ausland genau das stellen wir
mit diesem Haushalt sicher
und auch beim
Bundesverwaltungsgericht sind 12 neue
Stellen für einen klimaschutzssenat
vorgesehen da geht es darum
Planungsverfahren zu beschleunigen den
Ausbau der Erneuerbaren voranzutreiben
dass das eine querschnittaufgabe
herausragender Bedeutung ist das zeigt
sich daran dass Klimaschutz jetzt sogar
im Einzelplan 7 etatisiert ist und das
ist genau richtig so liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen
die wichtigste und nobelste Aufgabe des
Justizministeriums ist die Stärkung
unseres Rechtsstaates wo immer der
Rechtsstaat schwächelt sind
demokratiefeinde nicht fern um ihre
toxischen Thesen zu verbreiten sie
sitzen auch hier im Bundestag die
Freunde der Desinformation und der auf
wegelei die Freunde Putins da ganz
rechts als Koalition sehen wir im
Bereich der Hasskriminalität analog wie
digital ein dringenden Handlungsbedarf
im Bundesministerium für Justiz haben
wir dafür Stellen geschaffen die sich
der Bekämpfung und Verfolgung von Hass
und Hesse Hetze widmen als Mitglied
einer Bürgerrechtspartei ist für mich
dabei aber eine Sache wirklich zentral
gegen Rechtsverstöße im Internet muss
konsequent vorgegangen werden aber
gleichzeitig müssen freiheits- und
Bürgerrechte auch in der digitalen Welt
gewahrt werden
hier die richtige Balance zu finden muss
für uns DemokratInnen essentiell sein ob
online Durchsuchungen quellentheke oder
anlasslose Vorratsdatenspeicherung mehr
Überwachung bringt nicht automatisch
mehr Sicherheit so viel ist klar liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
umso wichtiger umso wichtiger ist eine
zielgerichtete Evaluation dieser
Maßnahmen genau das bringt die
Ampelkoalition mit der
überwachungsgesamt Richtung auf den Weg
die Mittel dafür stehen bereit und das
sind letztendlich Mittel für freiheits-
und Bürgerrechte und einer
evidenzbasierte Sicherheitspolitik auch
das steckt im Einzelplan 7 ich bin
überzeugt das ist der richtige Weg und
das gleiche gilt auch für diesen
Haushalt herzlichen Dank
Bruno höhnel war das für Bündnis 90 die
Grünen auch erst Mitglied im
Haushaltsausschuss die nächste Rednerin
Klara Bünger ist Sprecherin für
Rechtspolitik der Linksfraktion
sehr geehrte Präsidentin sehr geehrter
Minister liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der demokratischen Fraktion das 9
euro-ticket ist jetzt seit acht Tagen
Geschichte es ist wirklich bedauerlich
dass sie dieses erfolgreiche Projekt so
schnell wieder begraben haben
stattdessen soll es jetzt ein 49 oder 69
euro-ticket geben das als
nachfolgeticket zu verkaufen verkennt
die prekäre Situation in der sich viele
Menschen in diesem Land befinden
Millionen Menschen werden ab jetzt
wieder vom Recht auf Mobilität
ausgeschlossen sein wir müssen aber
nicht über die Fragen nur über die
Fragen der Mobilität sprechen sondern
auch über die Bestrafung von Armut in
diesem Kontext ich habe bei der
Deutschen Bahn nachgefragt wie viele
Menschen bei Kontrollen ohne Ticket
angetroffen wurden das Ergebnis ist
eindeutig bevor ist das 9 euro-ticket
gab sind über 214.000 Personen ohne
Ticket angetroffen worden im gleichen
Zeitraum dieses Jahres waren es nur gut
120.000 die Zahl der Menschen die ohne
Ticket gefahren sind hat sich in der
Zeit des neuen euro-tickets also fast
halbiert und es ist falsch was sie sagen
von der CDU das lag nicht daran dass in
diesem Jahr weniger Kontrollen gegeben
hat laut Informationen des deutschen
Verbandes der Verkehrsbetriebe wurden
die Kontrollen nämlich nicht
heruntergefahren während des neuen
euro-tickets
und was und was passiert ja Sie können
ja selber nachfragen und was passiert
mit Menschen die sich kein Ticket
leisten können und dann kontrolliert
werden sie müssen nicht nur ein erhöhtes
Beförderungsentgelt an das
Verkehrsunternehmen zahlen sondern ihnen
droht auch noch dazu eine Haft oder
Geldstrafe das Paradoxe ist wer nicht
schon nicht genug Geld hat für ein
Ticket hat erst recht nicht genug Geld
um das um die um die erhöhte
Entgeltzahlung für das Unternehmen zu
bezahlen und er hat erst und das was ist
die Konsequenz für diese Menschen
für diese Menschen hat das Fahren ohne
Fahrschein die Konsequenz die
Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe also der
Menschen ins Gefängnis damit bestraft
man Arme doppelt
viele machen sich gar nicht bewusst was
das konkret für die Betroffenen bedeutet
ihnen droht der Verlust der Wohnung und
des Arbeitsplatzes das haben sie Herr
Buschmann in ihrem Referentenentwurf zum
sanktionsrechts recht übrigens sogar
selbst erkannt und ich zitiere das
Schreiben sie in dem Entwurf in
bestimmten Konstellationen kann der
Vollzug der Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe sogar
zu einer weiteren endsozialisierung
führen etwa durch den Verlust der
Wohnung oder des Arbeitsplatzes
das bedeutet für viele Menschen eine
zusätzliche Bestrafung Stigmatisierung
und soziale Isolierung wenn sie das
schon in ihrem eigenen Referentenentwurf
erkannt haben wie so handeln sie dann
nicht danach was Sie gesagt haben eine
bloße Halbierung der Tage ist ein Witz
für die Menschen und hilft auch nicht
das Grundproblem der Bestrafung der
Armut abzuschaffen oder finden Sie das
gerecht dass Menschen wegen Fahrens ohne
Fahrschein ins Gefängnis kommen meistens
auch noch sogar ohne jemals vor einem
Richter gestanden zu haben ich nicht
und ich möchte das auch an einem
Beispiel deutlich machen Herr A wurde
wegen einer sogenannten
Beförderungserschleichung zu einer
zweieinhalbjährigen Haftstrafe
verurteilt weil er die Geldstrafe von
8000 Euro nicht aufbringen konnte nur
zur Verdeutlichung Herr A hat nicht
wegen anderer Delikte sich strafbar
gemacht seine zweieinhalb Jahre Knast
beruhen lediglich auf Verurteilung wegen
wiederholten Fahrens ohne Fahrschein das
ist doch absurd
mehr als die Hälfte aller Inhaftierten
und das wissen sie auch Herr Buschmann
in deutschen Gefängnissen sitzen eine
Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe ab das betrifft
jährlich 50.000 Menschen das ist doch
absurd das ist nicht nur eine
Katastrophe für die Betroffenen sondern
verursacht auch extreme hohe Kosten für
den Staat deutschlandweit werden pro Tag
450.000 Euro ausgegeben um Menschen zu
inhaftieren die eine Geldstrafe nicht
zahlen konnten häufig wegen Fahren ohne
Fahrscheins das sind 164 Millionen Euro
im Jahr und die Kosten der justizellen
Verfolgung sind dann noch nicht mal
inbegriffen dieses Geld kann doch an
anderer Stelle so viel sinnvoller
eingesetzt werden
genau zur Arbeit fahren Freundin und
Verwandte besuchen oder einfach nur in
die Natur fahren ist bisher häufig ein
Privileg von reichen Menschen das darf
aber nicht so bleiben Mobilität darf
kein Luxus sein sondern es muss jedem
und jeder ermöglicht werden deswegen
setzen wir uns auch als Linke dafür ein
dass es ein kostenlosen ÖPNV gibt und
vor dem Hintergrund der Tatsache dass
durch Krise und Inflationen noch mehr
Menschen sich die Mobilität nicht mehr
leisten können sollten Sie das Fahren
ohne Fahrschein entkriminalisieren und
schaffen Sie die ersatzfreierstrafe
komplett ab machen Sie hier doch keine
halben Sachen vielen Dank
Klara Bünger war das für die linke und
ja das Schwarzfahren also ohne Ticket
öffentlichen Verkehr zu fahren nicht
mehr als Straftat sondern als
Ordnungswidrigkeit gelten sollte ist
eine Debatte dazu haben wir eben unter
anderem auch schon Agenturmeldung von
1995 gefunden sie hält also schon länger
an Thorsten lieb spricht jetzt für die
FDP-Fraktion frau Präsidentin der
Bundesminister dr Buschmann verehrte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen Liebe
Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer gehen wir
zurück zur einzelplanberatung 07 sehr
geehrte Frau Kollegin Lindholz ums klar
und deutlich auch hier nochmal zu sagen
mit der FDP wird es keine anlasslose
Vorratsdatenspeicherung geben
Ausrufezeichen Punkt und wenn sie auf
die BGH-Entscheidung Hinweisen dann
lesen Sie bitte einfach noch mal
insgesamt durch und sehen sich die vier
Optionen an wir bewegen uns völlig mit
unseren Vorschlägen im Rahmen der
Rechtsprechung und das noch mal ganz
deutlich zu sagen
die Ampelkoalition liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen hat sich ein ambitioniertes
rechtspolitisches Reformprogramm
vorgenommen hier zeigt sich insbesondere
der Aufbruch dieser
fortschrittskoalition für dieses Land
und es ist gut und richtig so dass wir
dieses Signale setzen
wir reden heute über den
haushaltsmäßigen Rahmen für die
umfangreichen rechtspolitischen Vorhaben
der Koalition mit über 950 Millionen
Euro erfährt der Haushalt einen leichten
aufwuchssatz vor allem mit der
verbesserten stellenbesetzungsquote zu
tun hat gut dass es gelingt
qualifiziertes Personal für dieses so
wichtige Haus zu gewinnen und liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
ich hätte das wahnsinnig gerne heute
auch mit ihrer
haushaltsberichterstatterin Frau
Oppermann diskutiert was wir hier
vielleicht noch verändern und besser
machen können inhaltlich aber um eines
klar zu sagen hätte ich heute hätte ich
heute am liebsten über den Pakt für den
Rechtsstaat über den digitalpakt für
Justiz über erste Vorhaben intensiv
diskutiert nämlich über die Frage was
können wir als Bund dazu beitragen dass
wir gemeinsam Bund und Länder Justiz
weiter nach vorne bringen vor allem im
digitalen Umfeld aber wie wir sehen die
bundesratsbank ist nicht besetzt eine
Diskussion mit dem Bundesländern ist
heute nicht möglich
möchte ich an dieser Stelle auch noch
mal festhalten wir haben das vereinbart
und wir schlagen das vor im
Koalitionsvertrag
und zu wir stehen dazu als Bund wir
reichen die Hand der Bundesminister hat
es vorhin bereits angesprochen aber um
eines noch mal ganz deutlich und klipp
und klar von dieser Stelle auszusagen es
geht mitnichten darum und mitnichten ist
das unser Vorhaben unser
verfassungsrechtlich problematisch dass
wir aus dem Bundeshaushalt die
Personalstellen in den Bundesländern
dauernhaft finanzieren und genau dieser
Vorschlag ist vor einigen Tagen gekommen
ganz klares NEIN das wird es nie und
nimmer geben das darf es nicht geben uns
geht es um gemeinsame Projekte und die
sind dringend nötig im Bereich der
Justiz liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sagt justizklaut als eine Idee ich sage
gemeinsame Vernetzung darüber müssen wir
reden dazu reichen wir die Hand und da
freuen wir uns auf die Diskussion und
die Vorschläge der Bundesländer und wir
lassen uns nicht vorwerfen in der
Bundesregierung im Deutschen Bundestag
dass wir nicht bereit sind das zu
diskutieren wenn konkrete und richtig
gute Vorschläge kommen die aktuell
en her und ich sage ganz bewusst nicht
Märkte damit Märkten hat das reichlich
wenig zu tun geht diese Struktur im
Augenblick aussieht machen deutlich die
vorausschauend die als Ampelkoalition
waren als wir von Anfang an das Thema
planungsbeschleunigung
sowohl im verwaltungsmäßigen als auch
ein Gerichtsverfahren angesprochen und
angeregt waren das BMJ auch das hat Herr
Bundesminister Buschmann schon gesagt
ist vorangegangen hat einen ersten sehr
guten Vorschlag vorgelegt um im Bereich
der Verwaltungsgerichtsordnung nach
vorne nach vorne zu kommen mit der
Schaffung eben das schon mehrfach
genannten zusätzlichen Senates beim
Bundesverwaltungsgerichts das ist die
wichtige Antwort des Rechtsstaates zur
rechten Zeit Handel ist das Gebot der
Stunde denn nur wenn
planungsbeschleunigung Real und greifbar
wird dann gelingen die dringend
notwendigen Zukunftsinvestitionen in die
Bereiche Verkehr Energieversorgung die
wir dringend brauchen in diesem Land
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
abschließender Aspekt eine fundamentale
Aufgabe auch der Rechtspolitik ist und
bleibt die Förderung von Innovationen in
diesem Land mit den deutschen Patent und
Markenamt haben wir im Geschäftsbereich
des Bundesjustizministerium eine der
weltweit anerkanntesten Behörden für die
Sicherung von geistigen Eigentum es ist
daher ein gutes Zeichen für die
Sicherung von Innovationen in diesem
Land das auch das DPMA bei
Stellenbesetzungen gut vorangekommen ist
und es erweist sich als sehr kluge
Entscheidung den Standort Jena weiter zu
stärken um auch dort die Gewinnung von
Fachkräften zu erleichtern das ist ein
fundamentaler Beitrag ohne die weltweit
den die weltweit anerkannte hohe
Qualität der Entscheidung des DPMA und
unserer entsprechenden Gerichte
aufrechterhalten werden kann noch und
dem Bereich wie die Verfahren weiter
vorantreiben können das ist auch und das
will ich bewusst zum Schluss betonen ein
ganz fundamentaler Beitrag im weltweiten
systemwettbewerb auch auf die Frage des
Schutzes der und der Weiterentwicklung
von Innovation und geistigem Eigentum
auch im Bereich des BMJ warten also
zahlreiche Herausforderungen auf uns in
den Beratungen ich freue mich drauf
vielen Dank
soweit der stellvertretende Vorsitzende
des
Rechtsausschusses hier zum Einzelplan 7
Justiz und Carsten Müller ist der
nächste Redner auch erst Mitglied im
Rechtsausschuss
der justizpolitiker der Ampelkoalition
die Menschen im Lande und wir als
Opposition nehmen das übrigens ganz
anders war Herr Kollege Dr lieb und wie
sozusagen Rechtspolitik im gestreckten
Galopp ihrer Bundesregierung aussieht
das haben wir heute beim
Infektionsschutzgesetz gesehen da ging
einige Wochen und Monate Wechsel seit
ihr Beleidigungen und herab von
Mitgliedern der Bundesrepublik der
Bundesregierung voran und am Ende des
Tages mündete alles in einem
chaos-nationaler Tragweite das ist
nämlich übrigens die Wahrnehmung in der
Öffentlichkeit und meine Damen und
Herren was werden wir bekommen und wir
bekommen ein
ampelregulatorischen Flickenteppich in
der corona-frage aber dieses Chaos
nationaler Tragweite betrifft bei weitem
eben nicht nur dieses Feld der
corona-politik ich greife mal das Thema
Unterstützung der Ukraine auf Thema
Waffenlieferung wir erinnern uns noch an
die eine oder andere Einlassung der
Kabinettskollegin des Kollegen Buschmann
der Kabinettskollegin Lambrecht darf zu
ist vielmehr nicht zu sagen sie haben
eben selber sich aus dünne Eis der
Energiepolitik bewegt also die taugliche
gasumlage an der im übrigen der Kollege
Dr Buschmann an der Verordnung beteiligt
war die ist mittlerweile legendär sie
finden
sie finden in der Bevölkerung niemanden
mehr der sie dafür lobt und verteidigt
schon mal gerade gar nicht und meine
Damen und Herren wir gucken uns mal das
Herz der deutschen Wirtschaft an den
Mittelstand der Zeh meldet Land unter
die Bäckereien sind verzweifelt
ich will jetzt gar nicht vorhin ging es
ja um die Frage was geht viral und was
geht nicht viral in dieser Woche sehr
geehrter Herr Kollege bei dem Auftritt
des rechtsfreunds Habeck ist einfach
kein Platz mehr für andere Beiträge die
viral gehen können das muss man mal
zugestehen aber meine Damen und Herren
das Thema Insolvenzwelle ist ein
riesiges und es geht vor allen Dingen
darum dass wir den Mittelstand und zwar
den gesellschaftlichen und den
wirtschaftlichen Mittelstand in diesem
Lande unterstützen das fordert die Union
und meine Damen und Herren was macht die
Bundesregierung
das Justizministerium überlegt sich das
Insolvenzrecht möglicherweise ein
bisschen zu ändern da wird es noch im
Übrigen eine Reihe von erklärungs- und
erläuterungsgesprächen mit dem
Bundeswirtschaftsminister geben müssen
das haben wir alle erfahren in Wahrheit
aber braucht der Mittelstand konkrete
Hilfe und wenn diese unendlich peinliche
Auftritt des
Bundeswirtschaftsministers Habeck
vorgestern Abend zu etwas gut war dann
doch dazu dass er heute beidrehen musste
und er in Aussicht gestellt hat das auch
kleinere und mittlere Unternehmen in das
Energiekosten dämpfungsprogramm
aufgenommen werden könnten passiert es
im Übrigen noch nicht es ist eine
Forderung der Union und die
Öffentlichkeit fordert das und Sie
müssen diesem nachgeben und das finden
wir so interessant ist im übrigen dass
ausgerechnet unter einer von der FDP
mitgetragenen Bundesregierung der
deutschen Mittelstand so abgesebnet wird
meine Damen und Herren
ich soll das Justizministerin darum
Justizministerium darum besorgten
rechtssystematik in Gesetz und
Verordnungen zu gewährleisten das
passiert nicht ich will Ihnen mal einige
Beispiele nennen sie haben auf die
Länderbank abgehoben das Verhältnis
zwischen den landesjustizministern
übrigens egal welcher Couleur sie können
ja mal die grüne Kollegin aus Hamburg
Fragen und den Bundesjustizminister ist
ich will sagen ich will nicht sagen
zerrüttet aber es ist im Moment gar
nicht mehr gegeben weil es einfach von
Ignoranz geprägt ist der im
Bundesjustizminister bei der jumiko
machten eher gelangweilteten
gelangweilten zugeschalteten Eindruck
dafür gibt es eine Reihe von wichtigen
Themen Pakt für den Rechtsstaat steht in
ihrem koalitionspartag in seit neun
Monaten passiert nichts und wir merken
doch wie sie sich
raus zu ins Gebäude am
oberlandesgerichtszelle es stand im
Haushalt eine Verpflichtungsermächtigung
über 24 Millionen Euro es wurde geworden
von BMJ ein länderstaatsvertrag zwischen
den Ländern Niedersachsen Thüringen und
Sachsen-Anhalt denkt doch
unterschiedliche Farbzusammensetzung der
Regierung die Länder haben sich
zusammengerauf es klappt hervorragend es
bremst das Bundesjustizministerium und
kommt nicht in die Pötter und die Länder
stehen da und sagen was sollen wir denn
bitte noch tun meine Damen und Herren
muss etwas passieren und ich will einen
weiteres Beispiel liefern wir haben
einiges über die Ukraine und über
Freiheit gehört von Ihnen sehr geehrter
Herr Justizminister ich bin schockiert
dass sie ihr Haus die Mittel für das
Institut für ostrecht in den kommenden
Jahren sukzessive bis auf Null
zurückfahren wollen wir haben dieser
Tage die Justizminister aus Georgien und
der Ukraine da gab die haben sich
Unterstützung durch uns gewünscht sie
und ihre Koalition machen genau das
Gegenteil worin mündet das ich will mal
ich habe einen anderer Stelle heute den
bundeslandwirtschaftsminister gehört der
hat Max Frisch zitiert richtig gutes
Zitat krise ist ein produktiver Zustand
man muss ihr nur den Beigeschmack der
Katastrophe nehmen meine Damen und
Herren mit dieser Bundesregierung haben
sie die Garantie das aus jeder Krise
eine Katastrophe wird und die Menschen
im Land merken dass sie können das nicht
mehr weg diskutieren
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Wort
Sonja eichwede
sonja eichwege ist die rechtspolitische
Sprecherin der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr Bundesjustizminister
Buschmann werte Kolleginnen und Kollegen
der demokratischen Fraktion wir
diskutieren heute über den
Haushaltsentwurf des Bundesministeriums
der Justiz und damit über einen Bereich
der wie kein anderer für das Fundament
unseres Rechtsstaates steht oft wirkt
der wie ein Brennglas auf sozialen
Herausforderungen für unsere
Gesellschaft und unseren
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt
technisch gesprochen ist der Einzelplan
07 ein Haushalt der stark durch
Personalausgaben geprägt ist wir haben
es in der Debatte schon vielfach gehört
tatsächlich stehen aber diese Ausgaben
für Personen die unseren Rechtsstaat
nach außen repräsentieren ihnen
leibhaftig machen erwähnt wurde dabei
der neue senat des
Bundesverwaltungsgerichts der sehr sehr
wichtig ist und auch zeigt dass die
Regierung es nicht nur ernst meint mit
guten Ideen mit der die Frage der
planungsbeschleunigung mit der
Reformierung der
Verwaltungsgerichtsordnung sondern auch
weiß was es hier für die Umsetzung
braucht nämlich entsprechenden Stellen
in den Bundesgericht
neben dem Personal sind wichtige
einzelne Projekte in dem Haushalt
enthalten auf einige haben eine
Vorredner hingewiesen beispielsweise
möchte ich aber die weitere
Unterstützung der Magnus
hirschfeld-stiftung nennen die auch für
einen guten effektiven Rechtsstaat
zusammen mit uns kämpft im
parlamentarischen Verfahren werden wir
uns noch für weitere Projekte einsetzen
die es auch zu fördern gilt in diesem
Sinne
zu unserer Demokratie gehört es dass
Menschen auch Recht bekommen dass die
Justiz effektiv ist das haben wir uns
als ampelregierung vorgenommen dafür ist
dieser Haushaltsentwurf ein sehr sehr
gutes Beispiel da wir bereits auf viele
Haushalt tierische Details in der
Debatte eingegangen sind ist es mir ein
Anliegen noch ein Augenmerk auf einen
Bereich zu legen der eng auch mit der
Ausstattung der Justiz zu tun hat der
vom Bundesminister und auch von
Opposition teilweise genannt ist
wir haben es momentan mit steigenden
Lebenshaltungskosten zu tun ausgelöst
durch den völkerrechtswidrigen
Angriffskrieg in der Ukraine durch den
russischen Staat der auch uns eben vor
große Herausforderungen stellt deswegen
haben wir die entlastungspakete die sehr
sehr wichtig sind für den Zusammenhalt
in unserem Land denn wir wissen dass
soziale Härten insbesondere Personen mit
wenig Geld am stärksten treffen als
ehemalige Strafrichterin es ist deshalb
mir ein besonderes Anliegen auch auf
Personen hinzuweisen die eben von Armut
betroffen sind oder von Armut gefährdet
sind und sich in der besonders
wunderbaren Situation eine
Strafverfahrens befinden gerade in
finanziell schwierigen Situationen hat
ein Strafrichter eine Geldstrafe für
Straf- und Schuld angemessen gehalten
ist es aber dieser Person trotzdem
ohne Rücklagen und mit einem geringen
monatlichen Einkommen sehr sehr schwer
Geld am Monatsende zu entbehren um eben
einen entsprechenden Tagessatz zu zahlen
des Risiko dass die Strafe in einem
Gefängnis verbüßt werden muss ist sehr
sehr hoch hier müssen wir anpacken hier
werden wir anpacken hier der
Bundesjustizminister einen guten
Referentenentwurf mit seinem Ministerium
vorgelegt der jetzt ins parlamentarische
Verfahren geht ich will trotzdem
deutlich machen dass der Handlungsbedarf
hier auch im Vergleich zu unseren
Nachbarländern sehr sehr großes denn
deutschland hat im Vergleich in Europa
sehr viele Personen die ein
ersatzfreiheit Strafe verbüßen es sind
aufs Jahr gerechnet sogar mehr als die
Hälfte der Personen die sich in
Justizvollzugsanstalten befinden und
eben in einer sozial schwierigeren Lage
ein Thema auf das wir hier auch als
Regierung eben entsprechend durch eine
Überarbeitung die strafrechtlichen
sanktionensystems eingehen müssen und
eingehen wollen
das gebietet nicht nur die Gerechtigkeit
sondern es eben auch eine Frage Haushalt
tierischer Vernunft da ist hier bei den
Ländern zu großen Einsparungen kommen
wird in diesen politisch
herausfordernden Zeiten müssen wir für
eine gut funktionierende Justiz sorgen
für eine gut funktionierende Strafjustiz
für eine Umsetzung des digitalpakts für
eine Ausgestaltung des Paktes für den
Rechtsstaat sehr geehrter Herr Kollege
Müller wo ist ja Verhandlung gibt oder
Bundesjustizminister darauf hingewiesen
hat dass wir uns und sie sagen ja sie
sind eine rechtsstaatspartei aber eben
natürlich auch in den Grenzen des
Grundgesetzes in den
zuständigkeitsgrenzen hier bewegen
müssen ist vollkommen klar deshalb kann
der Bund nur strukturell die Länder
unterstützen aber dabei stehen wir auch
zu unserem Wort und Wissen dass das
gerade in der Krise besonders wichtig
ist zu tun
wir wissen dass der Rechtsstaat
effektiver werden muss dass die Justiz
effektiv ausgestaltet werden muss der
Haushaltsentwurf bietet dafür eine gute
Grundlage eine gute
Diskussionsgrundlage ich freue mich sehr
auf die anstehenden Verhandlungen und
die Haushaltsberatung vielen Dank
vielen Dank Sonja eich wede war das und
meine Damen und Herren sie sehen wir
schauen auch nach Schottland denn in
Großbritannien sind Ärzte besorgt über
den Gesundheitszustand der Queen sie
hält sich auf auf Schloss balmore auch
Teile der Königsfamilie sind dort schon
hingeilt
wir beobachten die Situation für Sie
Fraktion hier im Hause also der AFD
Liebe andere Abgeordneten der anderen
Fraktionen liebe Zuhörer und Zuschauer
vom Busch manchen es gibt ein absolutes
Ende der corona-maßnahmen am 20 März
2022 bis zu drohenden
demonstrationsverboten
ffb-2-maskenpflicht in Zügen und
ursprünglich ja auch in Flugzeugen weiß
nur ein Wahnsinn nur ein paar Monate nun
ist uns Gott sei Dank die maskenpflicht
im Flugzeugen erspart geblieben nachdem
Scholz seine Maske offenbar vergessen
hatte und Habeck die ganze Geschichte
nicht ganz ernst genommen hat auf dem
regierungsflieger der bestückt war auch
mit vielen Vertretern der Presse also
nur ein ffp-maskenpflicht im Zug nicht
im Flieger die das Virus scheint
irgendwie Verkehrsmittel abhängig zu
sein weil Leute was macht das
Justizministerium aus meinen aus allen
Menschen in kürzester Zeit
Maß balai handbricht Lambrecht die Liste
der gescheiterten Justizminister ist
lang und das Scheitern geht jetzt
offenbar mit Marco Buschmann weiter was
macht das Justizministerium aus einem
mutmaßlich freiheitlichen Geist wie
Marco Buschmanns eins Tor gab zu sein
das F in FDP steht für freie für
Freiheit inzwischen eher für Feigheit
für Fiasko für flachdenker für flexibel
für Freund Lauterbachs was waren das
heute für peinliche Lobhudeleien von
klabauterbach ihnen gegenüber er
Buschmann also ich wer vor Scham im
Boden versunken mit lauter macht mich
dermaßen loben würde und arbeite daran
dass dazu nie kommen wird
statt Freiheit statt des Geistes der
Freiheit regiert in Justizministerium
nun links grüner Quatsch an das kann man
das nicht
beziffern oder bezeichnen quer bunte
transgeschlechtlichkeit beschäftigt sie
offenbar über die Woche die Elternrechte
und elternstellung werden nach
Beliebigkeit demnächst verteilt Angriffe
auf das Bürgerliche Gesetzbuch massive
Grundrechtseinschränkungen drohen im
Herbst heute verabschiedet das
Infektionsschutzgesetz es wurde schon
einige Male erwähnt eingesetzt der
Schande meine Damen und Herren ein
Katalog der Grausamkeiten den sie da
draußen den Bürgern den Menschen im
Lande wieder zumuten statt Ende aller
Maßnahmen vor einem halben Jahr das
genaue Gegenteil ist Gedankengut und
Schaffen des Justizministers des
ehemaligen Liberalen Buschmann geworden
Carlo colodi lässt grüßen Carlo Coloni
ist derjenige der Pinocchio erfunden hat
ich weiß nicht wer von ihnen mal in die
angeschaut hat vor einiger Zeit da ist
tatsächlich der Kollege Buschmann analog
zu Carlo Coloni abgebildet worden das
dachte ich mir das stelle ich meine ich
überreichen das gleich stellen sich auf
den Schreibtisch Herr Buschmann dass sie
sich wieder daran erinnern was sie mal
waren eine Liebe an liberaler Politiker
in einer Freiheitlichen Partei die
Alternative für Deutschland meine Damen
und Herren die ist die freiheitliche
demokratische Partei in Deutschland für
Freiheit für Rechtsstaat für Demokratie
für Gewaltenteilung dafür stehen nur wir
wir sind keine Pinocchio Partei wie sie
alle anderen wir sind eine Partei die
ernst genommen werden muss und noch
viele viele Jahre hier demokratisch
schalten und walten wird vielen Dank
Stefan Brandner von der afd-fraktion war
das hier zu Justizpolitik und zum
Entwurf 2023 für das Justizministerium
[Applaus]
253,42 Millionen Euro sind davor gesehen
herr Präsident liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
also ich weiß nicht wie es Ihnen geht
aber bei der letzten Rede und
tatsächlich auch bei den beiden Reden
aus der Unionsfraktion gab es bei der
letzten gar keine bei den anderen nur
minimale Kritik am justizhaushalt ich
darf das als allgemein breite
Zufriedenheit mit dem Haushaltsentwurf
im Bereich der Justiz hier werden nur
darüber freue ich mich darüber freue ich
mich auf jeden Fall
das ist sicherlich auch eine
realistische und angemessene
Einschätzung Liebe
Kolleginnen ich meine sie haben hier
gesprochen über das corona-schutzgesetz
sie haben gesprochen über den Einzelplan
des Wirtschaftsministers sie haben
gesprochen über alles und jedes was sie
an der fortschrittskoalition schon immer
gestört hat das ist ihr gutes Recht ich
sage nur wenn sie nicht zum
justizhaushalt Reden dann müssen sie
schon damit leben dass wir das als
Zustimmung zu unserem Haushaltsentwurf
werden
Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist heute zu
Recht mehrfach gesagt worden der brutale
russische Angriffskrieg der Überfall auf
die Ukraine lässt natürlich keinen
Politikbereich unberührt so auch nicht
den Bereich des Bundesjustizministeriums
der Generalbundesanwalt ermittelt in
internationaler Kooperationen wegen
diverser Verbrechen
wir sind uns alle einig und wissen dass
dieser Ermittlungen nicht morgen oder
übermorgen vielleicht auch nicht
nächstes Jahr zu einer Anklage führen
werden aber meine Damen und Herren
die Geschichte hat gezeigt solche
Ermittlungen führen eines Tages zu
Anklagen direkt mühendes Rechtsstaates
malen langsam aber sie malen mit
insofern bin ich froh dass Einigkeit
darüber besteht dass wir den
Generalbundesanwalt auch mit diesem
Haushalt angemessen für diese wichtige
Arbeit ausstatten liebe Kolleginnen
meine Damen und Herren der Kollege
Müller hat es angesprochen wir hatten in
dieser Woche hohen Besuch hier im
Parlament wir hatten den Justizminister
aus Georgien und dann den Justizminister
der Ukraine hier zu Gast aber ich muss
mich schon sehr wundern Herr Müller der
Justizminister aus Georgien hat
mitnichten davon gesprochen dass er sich
unzureichend unterstützt fühlt soll er
hat im Gegenteil gewürdigt das
Bundesjustizminister Buschmann gerade
ein Kooperationsabkommen mit Georgien
unterzeichnet hat wir begrüßen es
ausdrücklich dass wir die Zusammenarbeit
im Bereich des Rechtsstaates Stärken
weil das natürlich auch ein Weg ist
Georgien in die Europäische Union zu
verhelfen aber Herr Minister Buschmann
wir meinen dass ein ähnliches Abkommen
mit weiteren Ländern mit moldauern mit
der Ukraine schnell folgen muss Liebe
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Krieg
in der Ukraine wird mit deutscher
Unterstützung hoffentlich bald enden und
danach dürfen wir die Ukraine nicht
alleine lassen der Aufbau und der
Wiederaufbau der Ukraine muss dann für
uns hohe Priorität haben der aufbau
eines stabilen demokratischen
Rechtsstaats in der Ukraine ist auch im
deutschen und europäischen Interesse
Justiz ist das ist angesprochen worden
Aufgabe des Bundes und der Länder
gemeinsam und deswegen ist es richtig
dass wir den ersten Pakt für den
Rechtsstaat hatten und es ist richtig
dass die fortschrittskoalition sich
verständigt hat dass wir ihn verstetigen
und vor allem um die Digitalisierung
erweitern wollen Justiz im 21
Jahrhundert kann nur dann Akzeptanz
finden wenn sie für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger auch digital erreichbar ist und
wenn sie sich auch digital gestaltet wir
wollen die Vorteile der Digitalisierung
für die ganze Breite der Justiz nutzen
ohne die Nachteile zu übersehen es ist
für uns völlig klar dass wir moderne
Tools nutzen wollen zur Unterstützung
aber es ist auch völlig klar das
gerichtliche Entscheidung immer durch
Menschen getroffen werden und nicht
durch KI da auch das werden wir im 21
Jahrhundert weiterhin sicherstellen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch das
ist hier am Rande bereits angeklungen
zusätzliche Stellen sind werden leider
in der Justiz auch notwendig sein für
euch wie das angesprochen weil wir
natürlich in wirtschaftlichen sozial
schwierigen Zeiten leben und weil klar
ist dass wir in den kommenden Monaten
mehr Menschen haben werden die
Rechtsschutz bei den Sozialgerichten
suchen die sich an die Arbeitsgerichte
wenden oder die zum Beispiel um in
mietrechtlichen Rechtsschutz zu bekommen
sich an die zivilgerechte Wenden es ist
wichtig und zentral und entscheiden dass
diese Menschen Zugang zum Recht haben
niedrigschwelligen Zugang und dass sie
vor allem auch schnell eine Entscheidung
bekommen im Sozialrecht geht es nicht um
große Summen aber es geht um Tage um
wenige Tage in denen man diese Summen
zur Verfügung braucht und darum ist es
wichtig dass die Justiz gerade jetzt gut
aufgestellt ist um schnell den Menschen
zu ihrem Recht zu verhelfen
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
der Minister hat gesagt die
fortschrittskoalition wird das
Familienrecht und vor allem auch das
Namensrecht umfassend modernisieren
Deutschland hat eins der restriktivsten
Namensrechte der Welt der Name ist ein
wichtiger Bestandteil der Persönlichkeit
und die sind insbesondere zum Beispiel
für binationale Paare kaum
nachvollziehbar warum sie Namen diese in
Spanien oder auch in Großbritannien
tragen dürfen in Deutschland wegen des
Verbots der Doppelnamen wegen des
Verbots von mittelnamen und ähnlichem
hier nicht führen können ein logischen
sachologischen Grund für diese
Beschränkung gibt es nicht und darum
wird die fortschrittskoalition sie
endlich endlich abschaffen damit den
Bedürfnissen vieler Menschen in diesem
Land gerecht werden ein weltoffenes und
Multikulti kulturelles Land wie
Deutschland braucht ein weltoffenes und
multikulturelles Namensrecht vielen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
nächster Redner ist der Kollege Axel
Müller
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrter Bundesminister liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren ich bin
beginnen mit einem Zitat aus dem Vorwort
des Einzelplans des
Bundesjustizministeriums da lautet das
haben wir heute schon gehört dass
Bundesministerium die Justiz ist in
erster Linie ein
gesetzgebungsministerium und es berät
die anderen Ministerien bei denen
Vorhaben erfolglos recht liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen rechts setzen
aber letztendlich wir die Abgeordneten
des Deutschen Bundestages wir Regeln
damit das Zusammenleben der Menschen
unsere Rechtsstaat gewährleistet
Freiheit und schafft mit den
unabhängigen Gerichten einen Verfahren
dass Konflikte staatlicherseits beendet
Konflikte die die Betroffene selbst
nicht in den Griff bekommen
es verbietet aber auch dass Konflikte
mit den Mitteln der Selbstjustiz
geregelt werden ich hätte mir das als
Studentinnen 80er und als Richter in den
90er Jahren nicht vorstellen können dass
wir irgendwann teilweise
Parallelgesellschaften haben die meinen
sie könnten ihre Konflikte außerhalb des
staatlichen
konfliktregelmanagements Regeln der
Rechtsstaat liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Rechtsstaat muss das
alleinige Gewaltmonopol haben das sonst
das Vertrauen in in schwindet
und das Vertrauen der grundsätzlich
rechtsstreuen Bürger und Bürger in
unseres Landes ohne deren rechtsstreue
der Rechtsstaat ja gar nicht
funktionieren würde leidet aber auch
wenn die wie die Rechtssetzung die
gesellschaftliche Debatte abkürzt oder
gar ersetzt und ich habe das so
empfunden beim Werbeverbot für
Abtreibungen und zu empfinden es auch
viele
Kollegen aus der Justiz wenn es um den
jüngsten Vorschlag des BMJ geht was eine
Reform der strafzumessungsvorschrift des
Paragrafen 46 StGB anbelangt sehr
geehrter Minister
Gesellschaftspolitik allein darf nicht
der Sound sein der den Ton angibt für
die Rechtspolitik und die Rechtssetzung
zudem sollten wir und das ist mir ein
echtes Anliegen darauf achten dass wir
Gesetze beschließen die sich in der
Praxis dann auch als ausführbar erweisen
drei Negativbeispielen aller Kürze das
erste die allgemeine Impfpflicht wenn
sie denn so gekommen wäre wie es ein
Teil des Hauses gewollt hätte wäre sie
nicht umsetzbar gewesen in der Kürze der
Zeit die dafür vorgesehen war weil den
Krankenkassen die das machen sollten das
Personal und das Papier fehlte die
einrichtungsbezogene Impfpflicht ist bis
heute ohne Wirkung geblieben wir haben
sie mit dem gemeinsamen Ausschuss
vorbereitet in aller Schnelle wegen des
Schutzes
heute ist sie praktisch bedeutungslos
geblieben
das dritte dazu gibt es Irritationen wie
ich es gesagt habe in der Justiz wenn
die die für die Rechtskontrolle
zuständig sind und damit nenne ich als
ehemaliger Strafrecht jetzt die
Strafgerichtsbarkeit als als Beispiel
das Gefühl haben dass ihre
Handlungsspielräume immer mehr eingeengt
werden und deshalb habe ich mir bewusst
den Paragrafen 46 so wie sie in
reformieren wollen noch einmal
vorgenommen
die Strafzumessung ist ureigens der
Aufgabe der Tat Gerichte das sieht auch
der Bundesgerichtshof so und greift
deshalb nur bei groben Fehlern ein sie
engen aber diesen allgemeinen Rahmen der
Strafgerichtsbarkeit und der der
Gerichte haben bei der Strafzumessung
immer weiter ein durch
einzelfallkatalogsvorgaben und das
verengt die Befugnisse es verengt nicht
nur die Befugnisse sondern das ist das
die negative Begleiterscheinung sie
erschweren damit auch die Beweisaufnahme
die sich auf weitere Punkte erstrecken
muss und konterkarieren damit auch die
Ergebnisse die wir in der letzten
Legislaturperiode mit dem damaligen
Koalitionspartner gemeinsam erreicht
haben wenn es darum ging die
Beweisaufnahme abzukürzen Beweis
antragsrechte zu kürzen und das
natürlich nicht ohne den Rechtsstaat
dabei zu beachten
und deshalb komme ich zu dem Schluss
dass es richtiger wäre und so sieht es
auch der Deutsche Richterbund
dass wir den Kurs fortsetzen den wir mit
dem Pakt für den Rechtsstaat gemacht
haben so sollen so sollte es ja auch
sein nach ihrem Koalitionsvertrag das
heißt dass wir gemeinsam mit den Ländern
für adäquate sachliche wie personelle
Ausstattung der Justiz der Polizei auch
zum Schutz vor haftgelegten sorgen und
insbesondere auch der Grieche Einsatz
noch zu Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe alle sagen
die Vollstreckung muss halbiert werden
ich rekoriere auf den Justizminister
Gold der FDP der vor über 20 Jahren
Baden-Württemberg das Programm schwitzen
statt sitzen eingerichtet hat warum
gehen sie nicht dahin gehen vor dass sie
sagen für einen Tag Arbeit werden zwei
Tage
Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe angerechnet
das muss man doch prüfen als letztes
bitte noch einen Satz der Präsident
vielleicht hilft es ja hilft es ja wenn
wir endlich mal begreifen dass die
Menschen draußen den bürokratischen
Aufwand den wir mit den Gesetzen hier
drin verursachen kommen erkannt haben
und uns diesbezüglich mäßigen das ist
mein Appell aber vielleicht hilft ja der
Normen Kontrollrat der jetzt beim DMJ
angesiedelt ist vielleicht nur dann
allerdings wenn man seine Ratschläge
annimmt danke schön
Axel Müller hat hier unter anderem an
dem Pakt für den Rechtsstaat erinnert
noch von der großen Koalition wurde
damals beschlossen 220 Millionen zur
Verfügung zu stellen und zusätzliche
Stellen bei den Staatsanwaltschaften und
an Gerichten zu schaffen
und auch die Ampelkoalition möchte
diesen Pakt verstetigen und ihn noch
erweitern um einen digitalpakt für die
Justiz
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident meine sehr
verehrten Kolleginnen der demokratischen
Fraktionen
vor einigen Tagen ist in Münster ein
25-jähriger Transmann gestorben malte
wurde getötet weil er sich am Rande
eines CSD schützen vor eine Gruppe
Frauen gestellt hat malte wurde getötet
weil er dem Hass etwas entgegengesetzt
hat malte wurde getötet weil
quierfeindlichkeit auch vor dem Leben
keinen Halt macht ich bin immer noch
fassungslos ich bin traurig und ich bin
maßlos wütend quer
viele Menschen werden in diesem Land
beleidigt angegriffen ermordet schlicht
weil sie sind wer Sie sind und zu vielen
ist das immer nur noch ein
Schulterzucken wert gerade deshalb ist
es mir so wichtig dass wir hier im
Deutschen Bundestag über malte sprechen
darüber sprechen was gerade los ist in
unserer Gesellschaft denn wenn wir hier
über unseren justizhaushalt einzelplan07
diskutieren dann sprechen wir auch immer
über rechtsstaatspolitik auch das gehört
zu einer Haushaltsdebatte
wir sprechen über das Leben der Menschen
in diesem Land das was ich in den
letzten Monaten in unserer Gesellschaft
entwickelt ist kein Zufall es ist kein
Zufall das Hass Hetze und Gewalt gerade
gegen Quere und insbesondere auch gegen
Trans Menschen zunehmen denn es ist
verdammt leicht gegen Kühe Menschen zu
hetzen es handelt sich um eine kleine
Personengruppe eine Personengruppe die
zwei recht verbreitet toleriert der aber
dann auch recht verbreitet mit
Unverständnis begegnet wird wir hängen
zwar einmal im Jahr in der
Regenbogenflagge vor unsere Tür aber
schauen Sie sich doch um wie viel Mut
braucht es auch heute noch sich als
queer zu outen auch hier im Deutschen
Bundestag wie schwer ist es eine
Wahlkreis als Abgeordnete nicht dass sie
dahlbild an der normalen Familie zu
leben wie schwer ist es als queer der
Politiker hier in Berlin nicht sofort
als Experte für Geschlechtskrankheiten
kommisität und Fetische herhalten zu
müssen
es ist dagegen so leicht zu sagen die
sollen doch lieben wenn Sie wollen
solange sie mich damit nicht behelligen
es dagegen so leicht über eine Trans
Person zu spotten wenn man selbst nie
tiefgreifend innere Konflikte über die
geschlechtserwartungen gekommen ist die
die Umwelt an einen stellt es ist so
leicht gegen queere Menschen zu hetzen
weil diese Personengruppen mit ganz
allein mit ihrer Existenz so viele sind
Frage stellt dass die Mehrheit völlig
selbstverständlich scheint und weil es
so leicht ist nutzen reaktionäre Kreise
genau diesen Türöffner meinen Keil und
die liberale demokratische Gesellschaft
zu treiben sie fangen an Transpersonen
nur insbesondere Trans Frauen als
Besserung darzustellen als Bedrohung für
Kinder für Frauen als Bedrohung für
einen ominösen gesunden Menschenverstand
sie tragen scheinbar nüchterne Argumente
vor von Frauenhäusern von
sportfrequenten sie wiederholen Sie so
oft ist auch in der letzten Talkshow
noch von einem sachlichen Problem Gerät
ist von einer Meinungsverschiedenheit
das hätten wir nicht gelernt dass so
schreckliche Taten wie in Münster erst
dann in der Zeit und Leiden landen wenn
der Täter nicht deutsch oder
römisch-katholisch ist als hätten wir
nicht gelernt dass sie erst dann breit
diskutiert werden wenn man Minderheiten
gegeneinander ausspielen kann
was dabei immer stärker in Vergessenheit
gerät ist dass es eben nicht um eine
meinungsverstehenheit geht es geht um
das Existenzrecht einer ganzen
Personengruppe die Stück für Stück in
Abrede gestellt wird es geht darum die
liberale Gesellschaft als Ganzes in
Frage zu stellen wir können diese
Entwicklung doch seit einigen Jahren in
vielen Ländern beobachten kleines
Personen sind die ersten deren
Existenzrecht angezweifelt wird als
nächstes werden Frauen abtreibungsrechte
zur Debatte gestellt und das Ende der
Rechtsstaat deswegen ist es wichtig dass
wir als Regierungsfraktionen das
selbstbestimmungsgesetz Einführen und
das antiquierte TSG von 1980 endlich zu
ersetzen
deswegen ist es richtig dass wir das
Abstimmungsrecht reformieren weil queere
Familien in unserem Rechtssystem immer
noch systematisch diskriminiert werden
und
deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir
Maßnahmen gegen Hasskriminalität
entwickeln all das ist
gesellschaftspolitischer Fortschritt für
der für einige Menschen unter uns von
existenzieller Bedeutung ist all das
sind Maßnahmen die aber für weite Teile
der Bevölkerung faktisch keine
Auswirkungen haben werden liebe
Kolleginnen ich habe über malte
gesprochen und über den Hass den
quierten Menschen Tag für Tag ausgesetzt
sind ich rufe uns alle dazu auf stellen
wir uns gruppenbezogene
Menschenfeindlichkeit überall in den Weg
wie es malte getan hat stellen wir uns
hinter den Rechtsstaat nehmen wir unsere
Verantwortung ernst schaffen wir ein
Land in Vielfalt vereint besten Power
malte restenpower
jan plobner war das für die SPD-Fraktion
hat hier unter anderem noch mal das
Transsexuellen Gesetz angesprochen das
wird schon auch länger ja kritisiert das
ist für viele entwürdigend ist wenn Sie
Ihren geschlechtsstand ändern müssen
unter anderem müssen die dort zwei
psychologische Gutachten einholen
Fabian Jakobi spricht jetzt für die
afd-fraktion
darüber lustig oder was herr Präsident
meine Damen und Herren
der Haushalt des Justizministeriums ist
einer der kleinsten und einer der
langweiligsten nicht weil er unwichtig
wäre sondern weil er zum großen Teil aus
den Kosten für das Personal und die
Sachmittel unserer obersten Gerichte
besteht und über deren Notwendigkeit
lässt sich eben kaum streiten
allenfalls an kleineren Einzelpunkten
könnte sich sinnvollerweise eine
politische Debatte entzünden etwa wenn
das Justizministerium den Bereich der
Justiz verlässt und auch in diesem
Haushalt wieder eine Viertelmillion Euro
an eine gesellschaftlich schädliche
Einrichtung wie die Antonio amadeo
Stiftung ausreichen will aber das sind
randaspekte interessanter als sein
Haushalt ist das Ministerium selbst und
der Geist der ihm innewohnt das ist in
einer hierarchischen Struktur zu förders
der Geist des Herrn Ministers und also
ein kluger und philosophischer Geist
er zeigte sich öffentlich etwa im
Februar als der herminister gegenüber
Frau Maybrit Illner als Lehre aus
Jahrtausenden abendländische
Staatsphilosophie formulierte es sei der
Schritt zur Tyrannei immer dann getan
wenn sich die Inhaber der Macht selber
aussuchen ob sie sich angesetzte halten
oder nicht
sie hat Ende als jüngst nun getreu diese
Motto unser Kanzler nebst Reisegruppe
befand der Maskerade sei es für ihn
genug und das Infektionsschutzgesetz in
seinem Luftfahrzeug nicht gar so
verbindlich da wusste man im
Justizministerium auch für diese
entstandene missliche Lage einen klugen
Ausweg man hat die Regelung an die sich
zu halten die Inhaber der Macht
erkennbar nicht geneigt waren kurzerhand
abgeschafft und so ist die Freiheit über
den Wolken seit heute wieder etwas
grenzenloser während der maskenzwang für
das buchstäbliche niedere Volk am Boden
fortbesteht aber das ist Wasser unter
der Brücke spannender der Blick in die
Zukunft was brütet der Geist im
Justizministerium weiter aus einiges ist
angekündigt darunter wahrlich
faszinierendes ein sogenanntes
selbstbestimmungsgesetz etwa soll
folgendes vorsehen ein Mensch der
Objektiv in jeder für seine Umwelt
relevanten Hinsicht ein Mann ist jedoch
für sich in Anspruch nimmt eine Frau zu
sein soll die Macht erhalten von allen
seinen Mitmenschen die aktive
Bestätigung und Bekräftigung dieser
Unwahrheit zu verlangen und der Staat
soll dieses Verlangen mit Zwang und
Strafgewalt durchsetzen
es liegt mir Ferne den Herrn Minister
und sein Vorhaben in religiösen
Kategorien fassen ihm gar dämonische
Qualitäten zusprechen zu wollen dennoch
möchte ich mit einem klassikerzitat
schließen und dieses zu bedenken geben
Zitat teuflisch ist es das Reich der
Lüge aufzurichten und andere Menschen zu
zwingen in ihm zu leben Zitat Ende in
diesem Sinne bedanke ich mich und
wünsche weitere erfolgreiche Beratung
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
nächste Rednerin Bayram Bündnis 90 die
Grünen
vielen Dank herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wir beraten den Haushalt für die
für das nächste Jahr und in der Tat
hätte man bei dem einen oder anderen was
hier heute diskutiert wurde sich die
Frage stellen können was hat es
eigentlich mit dem justizetat zu tun
der Herr Brantner hat dazu wie wir es
von ihm gewohnt sind nichts beizutragen
aber in der Tat liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen es gibt sehr viel zu tun und
sehr viel zu sagen im Zusammenhang mit
dem justizhaushalt und insoweit freut es
mich sehr das ist heute deutlich
geworden ist dass wir bei der
Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe demnächst einen
Gesetzentwurf verhandeln werden der den
justizhaushalt entlasten wird und dafür
schon mal ganz herzlichen Dank lieber
Herr buschmann
denn auch wenn die AFD sich hier täuscht
und nicht erkennen will dass das eine
Relevanz im justizhaushalt hat muss ich
darstellen das ist eben so ist dass wir
in der Praxis Menschen haben deren
einziges Problem der Umstand ist dass
sie zu wenig Geld haben dass sie sich
ein Ticket nicht leisten können
der führt dazu dass sie Geldstrafen in
Höhe von 15 Euro pro Tag zahlen müssten
die sie nicht haben die aber im
Endeffekt dazu führen dass wir bis zu
180 Euro am Tag ausgeben für Haftplätze
in den
Justizvollzugsanstalten der Länder das
wollen wir ändern indem wir den
anrechnungsschlüssel bei der
Ersatzfreiheitsstrafe ändern liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen aber es ist
auch kein Geheimnis lieber Herr
Buschmann dass ich mir da mehr
vorstellen ich kann mir vorstellen dass
wir den Straftatbestand im Zusammenhang
mit dem Fahren ohne Fahrschein so
herabsetzen zu einer Ordnungswidrigkeit
denn warum wird für Falschparken eine
Ordnungswidrigkeit angesehen aber für
fahren ohne Fahrschein eine Straftat das
wollen wir ändern das können wir ändern
und da hoffe ich auf Ihre Unterstützung
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
und überhaupt kann ich sagen beim Thema
endkriminalisieren gibt es noch so viel
Potenzial wie wir die
Staatsanwaltschaften die Gerichte und
die
Justizvollzugsanstalten
entlasten können ich sehe ihr nicken
lieber Herr Bundesminister
und sie alle wissen dass es eben auch
einen Bereich gibt indem wir den
Menschen endlich den Genuss
legalisieren können von Cannabis dass
wir aufhören Menschen dafür zu
kriminalisieren dass sie einen Joint
genießen wollen meine Damen und Herren
und da ist es für mich gut zu wissen
dass wir mit diesem Justizminister
jemanden haben der sich dafür einsetzt
dass wir einen Weg finden
europarechtskonform legal in Deutschland
die Gesetze so zu verändern dass es
endlich eine Realität wird dass die
Menschen in meinem Wahlkreis
Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg und Prenzlauer
Berg Ost tatsächlich
gleichberechtigt
Genussmittel konsumieren können mit
allen anderen Menschen in dieser
Republik und sie haben es ja
wahrscheinlich gehört dass insbesondere
Hans-Christian Ströbele der über 20
Jahre diesem Hohen Haus angehört hat und
wahrscheinlich wie kaum ein anderer sich
für diese
Gerechtigkeitsfrage eingesetzt hat meine
Damen und Herren lassen Sie uns doch
gemeinsam den Hans Christian Ströbele
den Gefallen tun und gemeinsam endlich
das Hand freigeben meine Damen und
Herren
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
das nächste denn das Wort die Kollege
Franziska hockermann
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen sehr geehrter
Justizminister Grüße und Bedeutung des
Einzelplans des Justizministeriums haben
ja viele meiner Kolleginnen und Kollegen
schon hervorgehoben und gerade im
aktuellen Zeitgeschehen betonen alle
demokratischen Fraktionen wie wichtig
doch der Rechtsstaat ist
gemeinsam mit den Ministerpräsidenten
den Pakt für den Rechtsstaat beschlossen
sowohl die Ebene als auch der Umfang
zeigen wie wichtig der Kanzlerin und
ihrer Bundesregierung die Stärkung der
justizbundesweit gewesen ist ein großes
unterhaken aller staatlicher Ebenen und
lassen Sie mich mal einen Satz zur
Lehrenden bundesratsbank sagen wenn ich
so schlecht von der Bundesregierung
behandelt würde würde ich mich hier auch
nicht hinsetzen zu diesem Beratung
das Bekenntnis der CDU geführten
Regierung wollte die Ampelkoalition
eigentlich aufnehmen im
Koalitionsvertrag steht dazu wörtlich
wir verstetigen mit den Ländern den Pakt
für den Rechtsstaat und erweitern ihn um
einen digitalpakt für die Justiz Zitat
Ende Seite 84 ihres gemeinsam Vertrags
falls Sie das noch mal nachlesen wollen
offenbar
scheint die zu spielen
gesellschaftspolitischer Sound ist ihnen
offensichtlich wichtiger verstehe ich
bei Ihnen als DJ ehrlich gesagt auch ein
bisschen aber wie würde ein eher
bekannter grünen Politiker sagen sorry
I'm not convinced denn Herr Minister
seit sie im Amt sind ist weder zum Pakt
für den Rechtsstaat noch zum
digitalpakt-
der Pakt für den Rechtsstaat ist bis
heute ohne Nachfolge und ausgelaufen
und Frau Kollegin Dilcher jeder von
unserer Fraktion weiß wie die
Veranschlagung des Pakts für den
Rechtsstaat gelaufen ist aber egal wo er
veranschlagt ist und verortet ist es
braucht halt eine Vereinbarung und einen
Pakt und den gibt es nicht mehr das
wirklich erste ernsthafte Gespräch zum
Thema digitalpolitik gibt es erst in der
kommenden Woche ihre Bedenken gegen eine
Verstetigung des ausgelaufenen Paktes
das in der bisherigen Form die Mittel
nicht in der Justiz ankommen würden
teilen wir nicht
sie sind Ausdruck eines großen
Misstrauens ihrerseits gegen die Länder
und vor allem gegen die
landesjustizminister
und sichergestellt wie sie vorhin sagten
ist gar nicht und schon gar nichts im
Sinne eines Fortschritts dass sie mit
der Länderebene fremdeln habe ich schon
in meiner letzten Rede zu einem letzten
Haushalt gesagt und schon zur ersten
Justizministerkonferenz sind sie nicht
persönlich gefahren und ich weiß nicht
ob das hier die Kolleginnen und Kollegen
wissen auch für die nächste
Justizministerkonferenz Ende September
haben sie bereits abgesagt
zu dieser gemeinsamen Konferenz mit den
Innenministern fährt nur Kollegin Feser
sie scheuen offensichtlich den Kontakt
und das Gespräch und diese Passivität
erklärt auch warum es im Bereich der
Digitalisierung der Justiz nicht
vorangeht
sie behaupten auf die Vorschläge der
länderzuwarten für die gemeinsame
digitalprojekte die liegen aber ihrem
Haus seit Ende Juli bereits vor der
ejustice-rat hat umfangreiche Kataloge
von Vorschlägen gemacht und ihre
Abteilung für digitales hat es auch
mitgenommen es geht um sehr konkrete
Projekte die allen Ebenen weiterhelfen
würden
ki-strategie der Justiz digitaler
Austausch mit der Polizei in einer
Beweismittel Cloud Entwicklung eines
bundesweiten registerfachverfahrens und
vieles mehr
das sind sehr viele konkrete Vorschläge
der Länder die jetzt aber auch zügig
angegangen und umgesetzt werden müssen
ich verstehe da ehrlich gesagt weder
ihre Zögerlichkeit noch ihre
verweigernde Haltung gegenüber den
Ländern
die Beschränkung auf digitalprojekte an
denen sie sich beteiligen beteiligen
wollen ist aber auch nicht das was im
Koalitionsvertrag steht und was den Pakt
für den Rechtsstaat verstetigen würde
ein weiterer Punkt der bisher
fraktionsübergreifend vorangebracht und
unterstützt würde ist die von Frau
Kollegin Dilcher angesprochene Stiftung
Forum recht auch ich würde gerne hier
zwei drei Sätze zu sagen aus meiner
Sicht kommen wir nämlich im Jahr 2023 an
einen entscheidenden Wendepunkt sie
schreiben diesen Ansatz der Stiftung aus
dem Jahr 2022 schlicht fort obwohl die
Stiftung 1,3 Millionen Euro mehr
angemeldet hat oder 1,7 vorgesehen ist
in errichtungsgesetz tatsächlich ein
erheblicher mittelaufwuchs wir waren
alle in der vorherigen Regierung und in
der vorherigen fraktionsübergreifenden
Beratung für die Errichtung dieser
Stiftung eigentlich einer meint
Sie Herr Minister und auch wir als
Parlamentarier müssen schon entscheiden
ob wir diese Stiftung wollen und wie wir
sie arbeitsfähig machen zwischen fünf
Millionen Euro und einem mittleren
zweistelligen billionenbetrag nicht
schon ein bisschen Luft und wir müssen
darüber sprechen sie befindet sich noch
im Aufbau sowohl in Karlsruhe als auch
in Leipzig entstehen die Räumlichkeiten
erst und das personales in der Besetzung
aber wenn es keine Planungssicherheit
für die eigentlichen Sachmittel gibt
dann ist ein Output im Sinne der
Stiftung eben auch nicht möglich
wir stehen zu dieser Stiftung und zu
diesem Zweck das will ich an dieser
Stelle noch mal deutlich sagen
[Applaus]
Papst enthält keine Entwicklung er ist
ein weiter so ohne Vision und eine
Vereinbarung den eine einen Einzelplan
der die Vereinbarung im
Koalitionsvertrag nicht enthält sie
setzen wichtige Vorhaben wie den Pakt
für den Rechtsstaat den digitalpakt
Recht und auf den Aufbau der Stiftung
vor dem Recht nicht um ich erwarte hier
im Laufe der Haushaltsberatung ein
deutliches nachsteuern herzlichen Dank
sagt Franziska hoppermann damit kommen
wir zur letzten Rednerin in dieser
Debatte
als vor dem Deutschen Bundestag und das
ist der Bundesrat im Reichstagswahl des
Deutschen Bundestages
[Applaus]
ja sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrter Herr Bundesminister Buschmann
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen als
Saarländer habe ich vor allen Dingen
eines verinnerlicht nämlich den Spruch
großes entsteht immer im kleinen genau
das merken wir hier in der Debatte auch
Rechtspolitik im Bundestag ist
vielfältig und es geht trotz der
bescheidenen Größe des Einzelplans 07
ums große und ganze und noch wichtiger
hier spüren wir gesellschaftliche
Entwicklungen in allen Lebensbereichen
direkt und unmittelbar gespürt haben
genau das auch viele Reisende in diesem
Sommer die an überfüllten Flughäfen
standen und mit viel Verspätung oder gar
nicht abgehoben sind vielleicht liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ging es auch
dem ein oder anderen in diesem Hause so
was macht man aber in so einer Situation
woher weiß man welche Rechte hat und was
man zu tun hat wir stellen fest der Weg
zum Anwalt ist für die meisten genau in
so einem Moment ein viel zu hoher
Aufwand denn die Rally Realität ist doch
dass nur ein Bruchteil der Betroffenen
ihre Rechte wahrnimmt und eine
Entschädigung einfordert leider muss man
sagen dabei gibt es heutzutage
Unternehmen sogenannte
legal-tech-unternehmen die sich dieser
Fälle annehmen das erfolgsrisiko
übernehmen und die Entschädigung für die
Betroffenen einfordern das ganze geht
online und schnell und da sind wir schon
beim Thema Zugang zum Recht und
Durchsetzung von Rechten es muss unser
Anspruch sein liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen dass jeder Mensch in
Deutschland den gleichen Zugang zum
recht hat und auch zur Justiz hat
dafür liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
müssen wir bestehende Ungleichheiten
beseitigen das geht einerseits über eine
gute Ausstattung der Justiz das klar das
ist aber nicht der einzige Punkt Zugang
zum recht heißt auch sichtbare
Strukturen zu schaffen die für alle
zugänglich sind so werden die jüngeren
Generationen einen anderen Zugang haben
und nutzen als ältere einen Digital
Native wird erst einmal googeln wenn er
oder sie rechtliche Unterstützung
benötigt sie sind Vergleichsplattformen
gewöhnt wenn ein Termin beim Arzt
gebucht wird maniert das vor allen
Dingen online gemacht als Legislative
müssen wir genau diese mit Entwicklung
mit bedenken
Zugang zum recht heißt auch die moderne
globalisierte Welt zu nutzen und unsere
fortschrittskoalition liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen hat genau das verstanden
der zweite Punkt der mit dem Zugang zum
recht fest zusammenhängt ist die
Digitalisierung das ist ein Punkt der
mir persönlich aber denke ich auch ganz
vielen von uns ein besonderes Anliegen
ist Digitalisierung ist sicher ein paar
breitest Themenfeld hier sprechen wir
einerseits über die Digitalisierung der
Justiz durch zum Beispiel die E-Akte
oder durch besseren
Informationsaustausch zwischen Behörden
Gerichten und so weiter denn
Digitalisierung wie der Kollege vorhin
schon gesagt hat ist bedeutet eben nicht
eine Klage per E-Mail einzureichen die
dann am Gericht wieder ausgedruckt wird
genau darüber reden wir nicht liebe
Kollegen und Kollegen wir sprechen aber
über moderne digitale Systeme die eine
Brücke schlagen zwischen der Justiz der
Wirtschaft und den Menschen hier im Land
wir haben im ersten Halbjahr dieses
Jahres bereits einiges geschafft das
kann man wirklich sagen als Koalition
wir haben zum Beispiel die virtuelle
Hauptversammlung von Aktien
Gesellschaften
dauerhaft
geregelt in unserem Aktiengesetz und
verankert wir haben außerdem die
digitalisierungsrichtlinie weiter
umgesetzt und dadurch online-gründungen
ermöglicht wirklich ein besonderer
Schritt in Deutschland das gab es vorher
in dieser Form nicht das sind wichtige
Schritte und jetzt müssen wir genau hier
weitermachen um als Wirtschaftsstandort
und starker Rechtsstaat weiter
erfolgreich sein zu können müssen wir
schon heute die Grundlagen legen für
digitale Strukturen das sehen wir gerade
an dem Beispiel legal Tech hier liegt
wirklich unglaublich viel Potenzial und
wir dürfen uns nicht abhängen lassen und
eine Entwicklung verpassen die weltweit
passiert liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Digitalisierung und Zugang zum Recht das
müssen wir immer zusammen denken sie
bedingen sich gegenseitig und hängen
voneinander ab sie sind die Grundlage
für künftige Rechtsstaatlichkeit in
Deutschland deswegen ist Haushalt auch
so wichtig es geht nicht bloß um Mittel
für die Justiz es geht um nichts anderes
als um den Erhalt unserer
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und damit auch
unsere demokratisches Systems
lars hat noch dies möchte ich mich
herzlich bedanken bei allen Kollegen und
Kollegen die an diesem Haushalt
mitgearbeitet haben ganz besonders an
bei unserer Berichterstatter Esther
dilsa ich freue mich auf die weiteren
Beratungen vielen Dank
vielen Dank Esra Limbacher war hier der
letzte Redner zum Einzelplan 7 der Etat
für das Justizministerium ist es
kleinste Budget allerdings in der
Bandbreite der Themen wohl dann das
vielfältigste denn das Justizministerium
hilft ja den anderen Ministerien bei der
Vorbereitung für andere Rechtsgutachten
und damit kommen wir zum größten
Einzelplan Arbeit und Soziales und die
Debatte findet gleich ihren Anfang mit
Bundesminister Hubertus Heil
ein bisschen Zeit hat er noch denn sie
sehen es die Abgeordneten müssen erst
einmal zu ihrem Platz kommen meine sehr
geehrten Kolleginnen und Kollegen unser
Land steht zweifelsohne vor großen
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
Herausforderungen vor allen Dingen
diesen Herbst Winter auch im nächsten
Jahr viele Menschen machen sich Sorgen
für Sie Ihre Rechnung bezahlen viele vor
allen Dingen kleine und mittelständische
Unternehmen haben Angst davor dass
Energiekosten auf der anderen Seite
fehlende Konsumnachfrage ihr Geschäft
beschädigt und viele Menschen machen
sich auch schon wieder Sorgen was das
für ihre Arbeitsplätze bedeutet
die Ursache dafür und das dürfen wir in
dieser Debatte nicht vergessen ist die
Tatsache dass wir erleben das Energie
als Waffe eingesetzt wird als Waffe um
den sozialen Frieden zu untergraben
genau das ist putinskalkül ich bin mir
sicher bei einer Größe der
Herausforderung das für eins miteinander
hinbekommen müssen putin wird unsere
Gesellschaft nicht spalten unterschätzt
den sozialen Zusammenhalt dieser
Gesellschaft und darum geht es auch in
dieser Debatte
wenn es ja nachzulesen was er versucht
westliche Demokratien destabilisieren
nicht nur die Ukraine zu überfallen
sondern uns zu schwächen aber ich will
ihnen sagen warum ich trotz aller Größe
dieser Herausforderungen unterschätzt
überhaupt niemand was das für eine Größe
ist
zuversichtlich bin dass wir Deutschland
sicher durch diesen Winter bringen
können denn zum einen haben wir seit
Anbeginn dieser Bundesregierung alles
getan um die Gasversorgung in
Deutschland zu sichern
die Speicher zu füllen Ersatz zu
beschaffen dafür zu sorgen dass die
vierte Stufe einer gasnotlage nicht
ausgelöst werden muss und das ist
Knappheiten gibt die zu
Verteilungskonflikten zwischen
Wirtschaft und Verbrauchern führt ist
eine ganz ganz wichtige Nachricht und
ich finde der Bundeskanzler hat er sehr
eindrucksvoll in seiner Rede in dieser
Woche deutlich gemacht es war harte
Arbeit ist
und klar ist auch wir müssen was tun
damit die Preise bei Energie runter
gehen beim Strommarkt hat die Koalition
beschlossen mit einer strompreisbremse
dafür zu sorgen dass wir eben nicht
durch Zufalls oder übergewinne im
strommarktdesign zulassen dass der
Strompreis noch weiter steigt und wir
werden auch beim gaspreismaßnahmen
ergreifen aber meine Damen und Herren
trotz alledem sind die Energiekosten
hoch und die Tatsache dass auch
allgemeine Lebenshaltungskosten viele
Menschen belasten sind Aufgaben den wir
uns zu stellen haben und deshalb haben
wir mittlerweile
entlastungspakete von fast 100
Milliarden Euro auf den Weg gebracht und
gezielt vor allen Dingen Menschen mit
mittleren unteren Einkommen zu entlasten
dazu gehört dass wir zum ersten Januar
die Regelsätze anpassen werden in der
Grundsicherung im neuen Bürgergeld dazu
gehört die größte wohngeldreform die es
in dieser Republik gegeben hat um
Mieterinnen und Mieter mit geringem
Einkommen zu unterstützen auch mit einem
heizkostenzuschlag nochmals dazu gehört
dass wir einen Geringverdiener gedacht
haben indem wir dafür sorgen dass
Menschen die weniger als 2000 Euro
verdienen nicht nur erleben dass die
Erhöhung des Mindestlohns der ja auch
zum ersten Oktober auf 12 Euro gehen
wird mehr Geld in der Tasche haben
sondern wir werden Ihnen durch eine
Senkung von Sozialversicherungsbeiträgen
auch mehr Geld in der Tasche verlassen
und das ohne dass der soziale Schutz im
Bereich der Midijobs nicht für die
Beschäftigten verringert
ich bin froh dass wir mit den
Beschlüssen der Koalition nicht nur
Entlastung haben für Arbeitnehmerinnen
und Arbeitnehmer mit der
energiegeldpauschale die jetzt zum
ersten September kommt und auch an
Selbstständige gedacht haben sondern
dass wir es auch hinkriegen dass
Studierende das Fachschülerinnen und
Fachschüler und das auch die 22
Millionen Rentnerinnen und Rentner in
Deutschland unterstützung bekommen die
300 Euro werden ankommen meine Damen und
Herren das haben wir in der Koalition
beschlossen
das Kindergeld wird angepasst auch der
Kinderzuschlag wird erhöht und meine
Damen und Herren es ist wichtig dass wir
auch an die arbeitende mit in diesem
Land denken deshalb stehe ich zu den
steuerlichen Beschlüssen die wir gefasst
haben es geht nicht darum dass wir
einzelne Gruppen nur im Blick haben es
geht darum die gesamte Gesellschaft im
Blick zu haben und dafür zu sorgen dass
dieser Gesellschaft nicht durch
putinskrieg zerrissen wird das ist
unsere Aufgabe der stellen wir uns
wir müssen aber auch die wirtschaftliche
Substanz und die Arbeitsplätze durch
diesen Winter bringen und deshalb bin
ich froh dass mein Kollege Robert Habeck
heute in seiner Rede in seinem Teil
deutlich gemacht hat dass wir ein
Schutzschirm auch für mittelständische
Unternehmen erweitern werden und ich
werde meinen Beitrag leisten auch in
dieser Zeit dafür zu sorgen
Arbeitsplätze zu sichern deshalb kann
ich Ihnen an dieser Stelle sagen wir
werden am nächsten Mittwoch im Kabinett
beschließen nicht nur dass wir den
vereinfachten Zugang zur Kurzarbeit in
diesem Sommer in diesem Winter weiter
verlängern sondern wir werden den
Deutschen Bundestag auch bitten uns alle
Handlungsoptionen für eine
wirtschaftliche Eskalation im Bereich
der Kurzarbeit zu geben das ist uns in
der corona-zeit gut gelungen denn Corona
war ja nicht nur die größte
Gesundheitskrise und ist es unserer
Generation sondern auch die tiefste
Wirtschaftskrise und trotzdem haben wir
den deutschen Arbeitsmarkt robust durch
diese Krise gebracht der Millionen von
Arbeitsplätzen gesichert
das will ich dass uns das auch in
schwierigen wirtschaftlichen Zeiten
gelingt deshalb wird die Brücke der
Kurzarbeit auch in diesem Winter den
Beschäftigten Unternehmen in Deutschland
zur Verfügung stehen meine Damen und
es geht also um eine ernste Situation
und es ist vollkommen legitim das in
diesem Hause jedenfalls unter den
demokratischen Parteien übermittelt und
Wege und Instrumente gestritten wird das
ist in einer Demokratie vollkommen
üblich aber ich bitte Sie bei einem
Streit um das Einzel nicht zu vergessen
wir unser eigentlicher Gegner ist sitzt
in Moskau er will diese Gesellschaft
Spalten er will uns verunsichern er will
uns von der Solidarität zur Ukraine
abbringen und das werden wir nicht
zulassen dürfen als Gesellschaft deshalb
bekräftige ich was ich kurz nach dem 24
februar von diesem Pult ausgesagt habe
ich bin der festen Überzeugung dass es
die gesamte Bundesregierung dass die
gesamte Koalition ich glaube die meisten
Demokraten hier auch im Hause äußere
Sicherheit und innerer sozialer Friede
sind zwei Seiten derselben Medaille das
müssen wir im Blick auf die
Herausforderungen vor uns haben wir
werden uns nicht spalten lassen und wir
werden diese Gesellschaft zusammenhalten
trotz aller Kraft die wir daran setzen
diese Krise zu meistern diese
Bewährungsprobe für unser
landwirtschaftlich und sozial zu
bewältigen dürfen wir dabei nicht
vernachlässigen dass dieses Gesetz diese
Gesellschaft nicht nur Krisenmanagement
braucht sondern sie braucht auch
Fortschritt
und deshalb werden wir Themen nicht auf
die lange Bank schieben die wir uns als
Koalition für die wirtschaftliche und
die soziale Erneuerung dieses Landes
vorgenommen haben
wir haben gestern beim fachkräftegipfel
beispielsweise darüber gesprochen dass
wir im Blick auf den demografischen
Wandel dafür sorgen müssen dass
langfristig nicht wie wir das jetzt
schon in vielen Branchen und Regionen in
Deutschland erlebt der mangelnden
Arbeits- und Fachkräften zur dauerhaften
wachstums- und wohlstandsbremse für
Deutschland werden darf und deshalb ist
es wichtig dass wir gestern mit
Wirtschaft und Gewerkschaften mit Bund
und Ländern und in der Koalition uns auf
konkrete Maßnahmen verständigt haben um
die inländischen Potenziale in diesem
Land voll zu erschließen dazu gehört
dafür zu sorgen dass wir mit einer
Ausbildungsgarantie dafür sorgen dass
möglichst alle jungen Menschen eine
Chance auf berufliche Ausbildung haben
dazu gehört Berufsorientierung wenn es
nach mir geht ab der fünften Klasse an
jeder Schulform dazu gehört Mobilität
dazu gehörten Angebot von betrieblichen
Ausbildungsstellen aber dazu gehört im
Notfall in unterversorgten Gebieten auch
überbetriebliche Ausbildung es geht um
den Ausbau der jungen berufsagenturen
die wir uns vorgenommen haben es geht
darum Menschen die in Berufsabschluss
verpasst haben mit der bürgergeldreform
eine Chance zu geben ein Berufsabschluss
nachzuholen bei der Bürgergeld geht es
nicht nur um die Frage der sozialen
Unterstützung der Entbürokratisierung
das ist auch wichtig es geht darum dass
wir Menschen und zwei Drittel der
Langzeitarbeitslosen haben keine
abgeschlossene Berufsausbildung eine
neue Chance eröffnen und im Zweifelsfall
sie nicht in irgendwelche
Hilfstätigkeiten drücken und das
Jobcenter sieht sie dann nach ein paar
Wochen oder Monaten wieder sondern dafür
zu sorgen dass sie ein Anreiz haben
finanziell aber auch die Möglichkeit ein
Berufsabschluss nachzuholen auch das ein
Beitrag zur Fachkräftesicherung
wir werden zudem vor allem die Frauen
Erwerbsbeteiligung Deutschlands erhöhen
müssen und auch Menschen die
eingeschränkt sind als Chance für
unseren Arbeitsmarkt begreifen und hören
abbauen und wir werden gleichzeitig
qualifizierte Zuwanderung mit einem
modernen Einwanderungsgesetz für
Deutschland schaffen das ist
wohlstandssicherung meine Damen und
Herren auch über die Krise hinaus die
wir betreiben werden ich hätte gern noch
ein bisschen mehr Zeit um ihn auch noch
deutlich zu machen was die
bürgergeldreform ist das werden meine
Kolleginnen und Kollegen machen ich will
Ihnen auch sagen dass wir in diesem Jahr
auch noch die Sicherung des
Rentenniveaus über 2025 hinaus machen
werden sie sehen also diese Koalition
hat die Kraft und die Entschlossenheit
nicht nur diese Krise für Deutschland zu
meistern sondern auch für Zukunft zu
sorgen herzlichen Dank
Hubertus Heil Bundesminister für Arbeit
und Soziales hat hier unter anderem den
fachkräftegipfel angesprochen mit dem
wirtschaftsbildungs- und
Arbeitsministerium hier erwirken möchte
dass es nicht zum Fachkräfte Mangel
kommt bis zum Jahr 2026 zu schätze die
Bundesregierung fehlen 240.000
Fachkräfte in Deutschland auch unsere
Wirtschaft unsere Sozialstaat machen
zurzeit einen dramatischen Stresstest
durch die Pandemie ist noch nicht
überwunden da treffen uns die Folgen von
Putins Angriffskrieg und die
energiepreisexplosion mit großer Wucht
zugleich dürfen wir nicht vergessen viel
viel härter trifft dieser Krieg die
Menschen in der Ukraine selbst täglich
sterben dort Frauen Männer und Kinder
wir wollen den Erfolg der Ukraine als
Voraussetzung für den Frieden
und ich danke allen die in unserem Land
sich jetzt für die vielen Flüchtlinge
aus der Ukraine und für die
Unterstützung der Ukraine selbst
einsetzen für ihren
ausdrucksstarken großartigen Einsatz wir
wollen dass unser Sozialstaat diese
Herausforderung gut meistert wer auf
einem dramatischen winterhofft wer will
das aus der Sorgen vieler Menschen Wut
wird der versagt politisch und der
versagt moralisch und er hat für seinen
schäbiges tun eine klare Antwort aller
DemokratInnen und Demokraten verdient
meine Damen meine Herren
wer unterstützen alle sinnvollen
Maßnahmen die Not vieler Menschen zu
lindern gut dass nun auch Rentnerinnen
und Rentner Studentinnen und Studenten
einer Einmalzahlung erhalten wir haben
dies nachdrücklich gefordert wir hätten
uns eine
gezieltere Einmalzahlung gewünscht mehr
Geld für die die bis weit in die Mitte
unserer Gesellschaft hinein jeden Cent
umdrehen müssen keine Unterstützung für
die die sie nicht brauchen
ein guter Ansatz ist es Sonderzahlungen
von Steuern und Abgaben zu befreien wenn
sich Sozialpartner darauf eingehen das
begrüßen wir ausdrücklich hoffentlich
nutzen viele Betriebe dies hoffentlich
können Sie es auch nutzen gar nicht zu
diesen Maßnahmen passt eine gasumlage
die die Bürgerinnen und Bürger und die
Wirtschaft belastet um auch Unternehmen
zugute zu kommen die dies gar nicht
brauchen wie sagt der SPD-Kollege Dirk
Kiese
handwerkliche Umsetzung bedenklich und
am Ende zahlt der Bürger drauf Ende des
Zitats sie hätten heute diesen Unsinn
stoppen können sie hätten heute diesen
Unsinn Steppen müssen schade dass sie
dies nicht getan haben
gerade in der Krise muss um jeden
Arbeitsplatz gekämpft werden am Samstag
hat in meinem Wahlkreis in Neuss die
Aluminiumhütte reinwerk ihr 60-jähriges
Bestehen gefeiert doch beim Gespräch mit
Betriebsratschef und Werksleiter war uns
nicht nach unbeschwerten Feiern zumute
denn es zeichnete sich ab was heute
Gewissheit ist ein Rückgang der
Produktion ein zurückfahren der
Produktion um
50%. das Warten auf Lösungen bei
Strompreis und Gaspreis bedeutet für
diese Unternehmen das Wangen um den
Fortbestand vieler Arbeitsplätze und
dies gilt erst recht für viele Klein-
und mittelständische Betriebe in dieser
Lage ist es unverantwortlich nicht alle
Möglichkeiten der eigenen Stromerzeugung
zu nutzen um der Preisentwicklung
entgegen zu wirken meine Damen
wenn wir die sozialpolitische Debatte
des Sommers uns betrachten man waren
viele Überschriften Wort geklingelt und
mancher Koalitionsstreit in der Ampel zu
erleben Sie haben ja das Bürgergeld
angesprochen Herr Minister Worte ich
vorgestellt von der FDP sofort und
nachvollziehbar kritisiert im Hinblick
auf die Neuberechnung der Regelsätze und
den weitgehenden Verzicht auf Sanktionen
und zwar zu Recht denn es wäre falsch
das Verhältnis von Grundsicherung und
Arbeitsentgelten grundsätzlich zu ändern
das hat der Koalitionsausschuss das hat
der Koalitionsausschuss nun ja auch
abgeräumt denn in ihrem Beschluss steht
ausdrücklich bei im übrigen
unveränderter Systematik solle und
darüber können wir ja reden über einen
schnellere Inflationsanpassung geredet
werden wie Sie wissen lehnen die
weitgehende Abschaffung der Möglichkeit
der Durchsetzung von
Mitwirkungspflichten ab der Landkreistag
waren zu Recht eindringlich verschritten
hin zu einem bedingungslosen
Grundeinkommen
Egge der Kollege Johannes Vogel der
Kollege vor Johannes Vogel hat wörtlich
zu einem fairen Bürgergeld erklärt dazu
gehöre das Zitat an dem vom
Verfassungsgericht bestätigten Umfang
von Sanktionen festgehalten wird Zitat
Ende wo er recht hat hat er recht sie
aber nennen das Einknicken vom
mitwirkungsverweigerer auch noch
vertrauenszeit das ist absurd das sollte
so nicht umgesetzt werden meine Damen
meine Herren ja es gibt Dinge zu tun der
Revisionsbericht der Bundesagentur für
Arbeit zeigt die Maßnahmen der
Unterstützung Begleitung und Förderung
müssen zielgerichteter werden wichtiger
als neue Titel und Prämien sind
Maßnahmen die aus Sicht der Menschen die
sie
zu ihm gehen auch Sinn machen hier ist
harte Arbeit erforderlich und nicht
einfaches Wort geklingelt und wir müssen
eben bei 1,5
finanziellen alles tun Menschen in
Ausbildung und Arbeit zu vermitteln und
was tun Sie sie kürzen bei der
Integration in Arbeit um 600 Millionen
Euro ein völlig falscher Schritt
der Arbeitsminister hat das Thema
Fachkräftemangel angesprochen und
fachkräftezuwanderung ihm wird ja
jedenfalls noch bewusst sein dass wir in
der letzten Legislaturperiode ein
modernes Fachkräfte Einwanderungsrecht
geschaffen haben ist deswegen die Arbeit
erledigt nein wir müssen viel tun um
attraktiver zu werden
schnellere visa-verfahren mehr
Spracherwerb schnellere
Berufsanerkennung all dies wird mit
neuen Überschriften nicht gelöst sondern
nur mit harter Arbeit dazu sollten Sie
bereit sein und ein anderes Beispiel sei
genannt ja ich begrüße es wenn die FDP
im Sommer stolz über die aktienrente
geredet hat ich hätte mir gewünscht die
SPD hat in der letzten Legislaturperiode
ihr Versprechen mit uns einen Neustart
in der privaten alterszusatzversorgung
umzusetzen auch getätigt aber jetzt sind
sie so stolz auf das Erreichte wo ist es
denn im Haushalt wo sind denn die zehn
Milliarden im zweiten Haushalt dieser
Ampel kein Cent angestellt und jeder
weiß 10 Milliarden in einem Kapitalstock
sind kaum in der Lage Zinserträge zu
erwirtschaften die bei 300 Milliarden
Euro Rentenausgaben eine signifikante
Rolle spielen sie reden schön aber sie
tun zu wenig so werden sie ihrer
sozialen Verantwortung nicht gerecht
meine Damen meine Herren
vielen Dank die Kritik vom
stellvertretenden Fraktionsvorsitzenden
der Unionsfraktion Hermann Gröhe war das
auf ihn Antworten direkt kann nun Markus
Kurt wir Bündnis 90 die Grünen sitzt er
im Haushaltsausschuss und im Ausschuss
für Arbeit und Soziales
Präsident
ich bin zwar Christ aber
bleibe bei den Grünen
[Applaus]
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Herr Gröhe ich glaube wir müssen aus
gegebenen Anlass mal über das
Menschenbild sprechen dass uns
offensichtlich hier trennt die
Ampelkoalition und sie und über die
Haltung mit der wir Menschen
gegenübertreten die
unverschuldet in Not sind lange keine
Arbeit haben und das wissen sie ganz
genau zum überwiegendsten Teil
verzweifelt Arbeit suchen wir von der
Ampel gehen zunächst mal von der Haltung
her von zutrauen Vertrauen von
Befähigung aus und wir wollen die
Talente wecken die in jedem Menschen
schlummern und wollen ihn befähigen wir
sehen in Menschen die auf
Sozialgesetzbuch 2 Leistungen angewiesen
sind keine Kostgänger oder Betrüger
sondern Personen die wenn man sie
unterstützt einen super Beitrag diese
Gesellschaft leisten können
und sie treten hier mit Unterstellungen
Missgunst und als erstes mit der
Vermutung hier an dass das Personen sein
jedenfalls zu beträchtlichen Teil die
gar nicht arbeiten wollten und dieser
Tage dieser Tage das ist die
Unterstellung die in Ehre der Subtext
der bei ihnen mitschwingt und es gibt
andere die sagen sogar sehr sehr
deutlich auf dieses der Art und Weise
Markus Söder hat diese Woche auf einem
Volksfest im Gillamoos gesagt alle
keiner Geld bekommen wäre würde ich es
Zitat gerne in der Tonne liegt und den
Diogenes spielt Zitat Ende also ich
frage mich wirklich wie verkommen und
wie niederträchtig muss man sein um vor
einem grölenden schon am Vormittag
betrunkenen Publikum auf Kosten der
schwächsten dumme pseudowitze zu machen
jetzt sucht natürlich jeder sein Niveau
machen sie das aber die Wahrheit ist
praktisch niemand im Arbeitslosengeld II
Bezug liegt in der Tonne gerne und
spielt Diogenes im Gegenteil die
Realität sieht so aus dass die Person
rechnen müssen dass viele von denen auch
versagenserfahrungen oder
misserfolgserfahrungen hinter sich haben
abgelehnte Bewerbung viele auch sie
haben selber angesprochen verfügen nicht
über eine Berufsausbildung einer
Ministerrats angesprochen ein Viertel ja
nicht überall über einen Schulabschluss
es ist ein großer Problemlage erst recht
wenn Kinder da sind und Personen die an
dieser Weise
Probleme haben sich selbst zu helfen
haben alles verdient dass wir Sie
unterstützen und das ist auch die
Zielsetzung von unserem Bürgergeld und
diese
aufmunternde und unterstützende Haltung
eint alle drei Parteien die diese
Koalition bilden
und ich sage Ihnen sie Sanktion das geht
ja auch von der doppelten Lüge aus
dieses Gerede das eine ist ja
tatsächlich dass die
grundsicherungsbeziehenden arbeiten
wollen was unterschlagen wird und das
zweite ist wir werden auch hier kein
bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen einführen
und die Sanktionen abschaffen das stimmt
doch gar nicht wir haben eine Sechs
monatige vertrauenszeit vereinbart in
der Koalition und es geht es geht darum
dass man erstmal grundsätzlich zunächst
nicht für ewig auf der Basis von
Vertrauen eine Arbeitsbeziehung zwischen
Jobcenter vor allem Managerinnen und
Fallmanagern und Hilfebedürftigen
beginnt und andere
vereinfachungsregelungen und
verschonungsregelungen sind gleichzeitig
das will ich hier sagen sind
Bürokratieabbau das sagen die Jobcenter
selbst wenn man nicht gleich vom ersten
Tag oder in nach einem halben Jahr
bereits die Angemessenheit der Wohnung
prüfen muss dann hat man keine
Fähigkeiten und Kapazitäten mehr im
Jobcenter
hat man keine Kapazitäten mehr im
Jobcenter um sich die Arbeitsaufnahme
und Qualifikation zu bemühen sagen die
Jobcenter selbst
und ich sage Ihnen auch
fähigkeitsaufbau
arbeitskräfteentwicklung ist
Wirtschaftspolitik das Stichwort
Arbeitskräftemangel ist hier gefallen
wir können es uns nicht leisten ein
signifikantes Erwerbspersonenpotenzial
brach liegen zu lassen und an
und an der Stelle muss man natürlich den
Konsolidierungsbeitrag den dieser
vorliegende Haushaltsentwurf ja auch
erkennbar
leistet Eingliederungstitel das Wort ist
hier gerade seitens der Union
inzwischenruf gefallen muss man sich
natürlich daraufhin noch mal genau
angucken ob es diesem Ziel der
Mobilisierung des
Erwerbspersonenpotenzials auch wirklich
gerecht wird das gilt auch das gilt auch
für den Konsolidierungsbeitrag der im
Moment verzeichnet ist bei der
berufsbezogenen Sprachförderung von
ZuwandererInnen und Zuwanderern das ist
eine das ist eine Entwicklung die dort
festgeschrieben ist im Haushalt die ist
gemacht worden als es die Ukraine Kriege
und die Flüchtlinge aus der Ukraine
überwiegend ja auch qualifizierte Frauen
noch nicht gehabt ich glaube wir würden
uns wirklich ein Schaden zufügen als
Bundesrepublik Deutschland und als
Volkswirtschaft wenn wir auch diese
Arbeitskräfte nicht nur in ihrem eigenen
Sinne sondern auch für unsere Wirtschaft
nicht
großen beziehungsweise nutzen hört sich
gemein an befähigen würden dass wir hier
an dieser Stelle auch zum Guten
Zusammenleben in diesem Land kommen und
wenn sie es nicht verstanden haben
wiederhole ich noch mal für Sie die
berufsbezogene Deutschförderung werden
wir uns noch mal genau angucken denn das
ist eine wichtige Brücke zur Stärkung
von beschäftigt und
Beschäftigungsfähigkeit es wird alles
nicht zum Nulltarif zu haben sein wir
werden auch nicht unendliches tun können
aber wir tun alles um die Würde und die
Zukunft von Menschen hier zu
unterstützen an dieser Stelle mit diesem
Haushalt und in diesem Sinne freue ich
mich auf die gemeinsamen Beratung vielen
dank vielen Dank zum Schluss wurde
Markus Kurt dann doch wieder
versöhnlicher ist hier in seiner Rede
unter anderem auch das Bürgergeld
eingegangen das ja ab dem 1 Januar Hartz
IV ablösen soll unter anderem mit einer
größeren Grundsicherung von rund um 500
Euro pro Monat Jürgen Pohl spricht als
nächster Mitglied der afd-fraktion
herr Präsident
verehrte Kollegen Werte Bürger zu Hause
an den Geräten
der vorliegende Haushaltsentwurf ist ein
Haushalt der Konzept und
Ahnungslosigkeit zeigt das links grüne
Case nicht nur den Zahlen und er kann
die Zerstrittenheit der Ampelkoalition
hinter die Kulissen nicht verdecken es
ist ein Haushalt der Ideologen Träume
und Kostgänger nicht aber ein Haushalt
der fleißigen und vernünftigen in unser
Land
kurzum eine skandalöse
Realitätsverweigerung kennzeichnet
diesen Haushalt was ist Realität in
Deutschland heute
Realität sind die vergessenen Rentner
also jeder Teil des Volkes der dieses
Land aufgebaut hat und die Wohlstand der
Wirtschaft hat es sind die
Leistungsträger von gestern die nicht
glauben können dass sie sich nach einem
arbeitsreichen Leben mit Fragen des
Heizens im Winter oder Stromsperren
aufgrund nicht mehr bezahlbarer
energierrichtung befassen müssen meine
Damen und Herren der Regierung die
Energiearmut befeuert die Altersarmut
und das ist das zwischen der Ergebnis
ihrer ampelregierung
ihre jämmerlichen 300 Euro reichen
niemals um die Preissteigerung bei
lebensmittelkraftstoffen Heil zu direkte
Energie auszugleichen aber nicht nur die
Renten auch ein Großteil der heutigen
Arbeitnehmer weiß nicht mehr wie es
weitergeht
Existenzängste erfassen die
Mittelschicht so geht die Paritätische
Wohlfahrtsverband zu Recht von Millionen
Arbeitnehmern aus die in diesem Winter
in Armut fallen werden hören sie zu die
untersten 30 Prozent der Einkommen auf
der einkommenskala haben keine Rücklagen
und werden für die verkorkte Energie-
hat euch
kurzarbeiterbälle die auf uns zukommt
die morgen schon anbrechen kann wenn die
Betriebe die Leute lieber nach Hause
schicken als mit hohen Kosten arbeiten
zu lassen hierauf hat er einzuplan 11
überhaupt keine Antwort stattdessen
gönnen wir uns Luxus wir gönnen uns die
Einwanderung von 100.000 Ukrainern wenn
das Arbeitslosengeld II toll wir
verschenken teure Rüstungsprodukte in
ein Kriegsgebiet wir können uns ein
unheilvolles Bürgergeld das so gar nicht
in Zeiten von Fachkräftemangel und
überbelasteten sozialkräften geben
durfte
dann habe ich nicht verstanden gemeint
ist ein Grundeinkommen ohne
Sanktionsmöglichkeit der
Arbeitsverwaltung da fangen da haben sie
ein falsches Menschenbild vor Sie haben
ein sozialistisches Menschenbild vor
sich sie sehen die soziale Hängematte
und wollen die Leute dorthin legen das
ist das und dies auf Kosten der
Steuerzahler und das ist falsch
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren ich möchte
auf meinen Wahlkreis eingehen der
Kyffhäuserkreis er gehört zu den
Landkreisen mit den prozentual am
meisten
mit Pendlern weil sie zuhören wenn sie
nicht zuhören wollen dass der Ausgang
gut danke schön wir kommen zurück zu
meinem Wahlkreis dem Kyffhäuserkreis er
gehört zu den Landkreisen mit dem
prozentual meisten Berufspendlern in
Deutschland die Menschen brauchen Arbeit
die Arbeit muss mit dem KFZ erfahren
werden
Ostdeutschland mit seiner Energie und
ölabhängigen Infrastruktur darf nicht
das erste Opfer einer gänzlich
verfehlten links grünen energiebinden
sein die müssen schnell Lösungen
gefunden werden das Credo der
Alternative für Deutschland ist
Arbeitsschutz am besten vor Armut das
ist es sehr geehrte Damen und Herren wir
stehen vor einer rekordahmut die das
Land noch nicht gesehen hat da können
sie dazwischen buchen eine von der
Politik
vorsätzlicher beigeführte Energie- und
Wirtschaftskrise erfasst breite
Bevölkerungsschichten und die Regierung
stolpert die Entwicklung hinterher meine
Damen und Herren von den
Regierungsparteien wir brauchen keine
halbherzige entlastungspakete brauchen
wir nicht
öffnen Sie stattdessen wallstream 2
beenden Sie die unsinnigen Sanktionen
die nur deutsche Bürger und die deutsche
Wirtschaft schädigen produzieren sie
Strom mit meine Damen und Herren von der
Regierung ich erinnere an ihren Amtszeit
erfüllen sie ihn wenn sie Schaden von
deutschen Völker ab danke schön
vielen Dank Jürgen Pulver das für die
afd-fraktion
Claudia raffelhöschen spricht jetzt für
die FDP auf sie ist Mitglied im
Haushalts- und Finanzausschuss
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen seit zwei
Jahren befinden wir uns nun im
krisenmodus mit Corona und der Ukraine
uns beschäftigt nicht nur die
exorbitante Inflation sondern wir
stecken auch in einer gravierenden
Energiekrise und stehen vor großen
demografischen Herausforderungen
kein Haushalt ist so unmittelbar von den
daraus resultierenden Konsequenzen
betroffen wie der Etat des Einzelplan 11
die Gesamtsumme der Ausgaben für das
Jahr 2023 beläuft sich jetzt schon auf
rund 163 Milliarden Euro und damit auf
rund 2,2 Milliarden Euro mehr als im
Haushalt 22
im Gesamtbudget SGB II steht im
Haushaltsjahr 23 zwar im soll weniger
zur Verfügung also im Haushaltsjahr 22
aufgrund der reste-regelung und des
passiv aktivtransfers bewegen wir uns
aber weiterhin auf hohem Niveau und
budgetieren hier bedarfsgerecht das
Bundesministerium für Arbeit und
Soziales leistet damit seinen Beitrag
zur vereinbarten
Haushaltskonsolidierung wir nutzen die
uns zur Verfügung stehenden Mitteln noch
effizienter und das ist gerade in den
aktuellen Zeiten wirklich wichtig im
Vergleich zum Jahr 2019 also dem vor
corona-niveau und unter Einbeziehung der
ausgabereste Pro Erwerbstätigen
Leistungsberechtigten stehen pro Kopf
sogar rund 170 Euro mehr zur Verfügung
kommen wir jetzt zur Rente die Leistung
des Bundes an die Rentenversicherung
steigen steigen gegenüber dem Vorjahr
deutlich um 4,1 Milliarden Euro auf
knapp
113 Milliarden Euro auch wenn es sich
bei diesen Ansätzen um Mittel für
gesetzliche Pflichtleistungen handelt so
dürfen wir nicht vergessen dass uns der
demografische Wandel vor enorme
Herausforderungen stellen wird
wir werden diese Welle nicht mit immer
mehr Geld aus den Staatskassen brechen
können das bekräftigt auch der
Bundesrechnungshof der da sagt dass der
Automatismus zwischen dem greifen der
Beitragssatz Garantie und Erhöhung des
Bundeszuschusses durchbrochen werden
sollte
das geht aber nur wenn gesetzlich
nachgebessert wird
ein Wort noch zum Kurzarbeitergeld es
ist eines
der ersten Instrumente im Baukasten des
modernen Sozialstaates und hat sich in
den Hochphasen der corona-pandemie mit
lockdowns und Ausgangssperren bewährt
die aktuell geltenden Sonderregeln zum
erleichterten Zugang gelten
glücklicherweise noch bis zum Ende
diesen Jahres dürfen aber nicht zum
Dauerzustand werden denn wenn sich die
Konjunktur wieder gut entwickelt und der
arbeitsmarktaufnahmefähig bleibt dann
ist es wichtig dass die Arbeitskräfte
auch dem Arbeitsmarkt zur Verfügung
stehen
der Einzelplan 11 ist nicht nur der
größte Etat im Bundeshaushalt er ist
doch derjenige der in den letzten
Jahrzehnten am schnellsten gewachsen ist
annähernd jeder dritte Euro den die
Erwerbstätigen erwirtschaften wird hier
umverteilt und da die demografische
Krise sowohl die Corona als auch die
ukraine-krise bei weitem in den Schatten
stellen wird gilt es in den nächsten
Jahren auch hier strukturell
nachzubessern
eines kann man gar nicht oft genug
wiederholen und verdeutlichen wir werden
und müssen die Schuldenbremse im
kommenden Jahr wieder einhalten das ist
ein großer liberaler Erfolg und aus
Gründen der Generationengerechtigkeit
zwingend erforderlich
und das ist keine wie hier gestern im
Plenum geäußerte Laune des
Finanzministers sondern Teil unseres
Grundgesetzes
unser Ziel darf es selbstverständlich
nicht sein den Sozialstaat einfach zu
kürzen vielmehr müssen wir dafür sorgen
dass mehr Menschen wieder in Arbeit
finden mehr qualifizierte Arbeitskräfte
in unseren Arbeitsmarkt gelangen und
unsere Produktivität also das
Immunsystem
unserer Volkswirtschaft dadurch gestärkt
wird nur so können wir resilient werden
gegenüber der demografischen und anderen
möglichen Krisen die noch auf uns warten
und nun noch ein Wort an die
Bundesländer
ich bin absolut empört darüber dass der
vom Bund mitfinanzierte härtefallfonds
für jüdische Zuwanderer auch im Jahr
2023 wieder an den Ländern scheitert
eine halbe Milliarde Euro hätte der Bund
zur Verfügung gestellt und was tun die
Länder sie haben den BMS nicht einmal
auf die letzte formale Anfrage
geantwortet auch wir ampelhaushälter
haben mehrfach angemahnt dass eine
schnelle Lösung her muss seit Mai sind
wir aber lediglich vertröstet worden das
ist bei diesem wichtigen Thema wirklich
tragisch gerade
gerade vor dem Hintergrund dass die
Länder gegenüber dem Bund deutlicher
Einnahmeüberschüsse aufweisen die halbe
Milliarde wird nun haushaltstisch
verpuffen das geht besser Liebe
Ministerpräsidenten und
Ministerpräsidenten es wäre im Übrigen
schön gewesen wenn Sie den wichtigen
Haushaltsdebatten zumindest in Teilen
ihre Präsenz erwiesen hätten
vor uns liegen nun wirklich intensive
Wochen der Beratung und eines ist in
diesem Jahr wirklich fundamental gerade
weil unsere Volkswirtschaft so stark ist
können wir uns diesen zu sozial-etat
leisten und das gut so aber es ist gar
nicht auszudenken wenn Bäckereien und
Blumenläden unser leistungsstarker
Mittelstand und die Industrie in dem
Wintermonaten vorübergehend ihre Arbeit
einstellen müssten denn dann Mangel
lieben Kolleginnen und Kollegen wäre
nicht nur unser Wohlstand sondern auch
unser Sozialetat gefährdet ich danke
Ihnen
Claudia raffelhövision betont hier noch
mal die Nötigkeit zurück
Bundesarbeitsminister Hubertus Heil hat
sich zuletzt da doch etwas anders
geäußert wenn wir in eine massive
Rezension Schlitter muss man die Frage
ob die Schuldenbremse einzuhalten ist in
der Koalition neu bewerten sagte er noch
im Juli der Etat ist der größte des
Bundeshaushaltes das wurde gesagt und
ich will auch eindrücklich so
ausdrücklich sagen dass wir als LINKE es
richtig finden dass es ein Zuschuss von
112,4 Milliarden Euro für die
gesetzliche Rentenversicherung gibt das
findet unseren Unterstützung das Problem
ist nur wenn Sie diesen Zuschuss
abziehen vom gesamt Etat bleiben etwas
über 50 Milliarden Euro für Arbeit und
Soziales übrig und gestern haben wir ja
über den Einzelplan 14 also Rüstung
Verteidigung gesprochen nach NATO
Kriterien sind in diesem Einzelplan 64
Milliarden Euro und ich finde das ist
ein Missverhältnis hier gehört
nachgesteuert
meine Damen und Herren
14 Millionen Menschen leben in Armut das
ist ein Negativ Rekord ein Rekord den
wir niemals hinnehmen werden unser Ziel
ist es dass in unserem reichenland
Menschen nicht in Armut leben dürfen und
es ist möglich mit einem gerechten
Steuersystem und dafür kämpfen wir
nun muss man sich eigentlich mal die
Frage stellen warum sind denn so viele
Menschen in unserem Land Arm seit
1998 mit einer Unterbrechung von vier
Jahren war die Sozialdemokratie immer an
der Regierung beteiligt und hat immer
die Ressorts für Arbeit Soziales und so
weiter verwaltet
wenn wir aber uns die Entwicklung
anschauen sehen wir dass die Anzahl der
Armen gewachsen ist die Anzahl der
Empfänger von Grundsicherung im Alter
hat sich seit 2001 verdoppelt das kann
doch nicht sein aber ich kann Ihnen
erklären wie es dazu gekommen ist mit
den Hartz-IV-Gesetzen haben sie schlecht
bezahlte Arbeit geschaffen und nur gute
Arbeit sichert gute Rente meine Damen
und Herren wir als LINKE fordern eine
armutsfeste Rente Menschen die 40 Jahre
eingezahlt haben sollen mit 60 Jahren in
Rente gehen können das wäre gerecht
meine Damen und Herren
das
Entlastungspaket ist ein Tropfen auf den
heißen Stein durch die galoppierende
Inflation wird es aufgesogen wer zum
Beispiel als Alleinerziehende und das
sind ja in der Regel Frauen zwei Kinder
zu versorgen hat wird nicht einmal zur
Hälfte entlastet wer soll eigentlich
Ihrer Meinung nach die andere Hälfte
bezahlen meine Damen und Herren der
Hartz-IV-Satz soll auf 500 Euro
angehoben werden das reicht natürlich
überhaupt nicht der Paritätische
Wohlfahrtsverband fordert ein
Hartz-IV-Satz von 678 Euro wir
unterstützen das wir sagen 687 aber das
ist die richtige Forderung die wir voll
und ganz unterstützen wir wollen das
Haushalte mit niedrigen und mittleren
ein ein Jahr lang monatlich 125 Euro
plus 50 Euro für jedes Familienmitglied
erhalten wir wollen in unserem Land
Gerechtigkeit Armut nehmen vielen Dank
soweit die stellvertretende Fraktion zu
versetzen in der Linken Gesine Lötzsch
auf sie folgten und Katrin Michel
Mitglied im Haushaltsausschuss und
Mitglied der SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrter Herr Minister liebe Kolleginnen
und Kollegen ceszten
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz hat in seiner
starken Rede die er gestern hier genau
an dieser Stelle hielt sehr recht als er
sagte in schweren Zeiten wächst unser
Land über sich hinaus wir haben eine
gute Tradition uns unterzuhaken wenn es
schwierig wird und genau in dieser
Tradition stehen auch die Verhandlungen
um den Bundeshaushalt für das kommende
Jahr wir sind nur zusammen stark das
gilt für die Zusammenarbeit in der
Koalition und zwischen den
demokratischen Fraktionen im Deutschen
Bundestag wie auch für unsere
Gesellschaft insgesamt
die Einlassung der Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus der Opposition zeigen aber
auch heute ganz deutlich laute Worte
polemisches Schüren von Ängsten bis an
den Rand der Erträglichkeit
konstruktive Vorschläge fehlanzeige
in einer derart schwierigen Lage in der
sich unser Land aktuell befindet ist
konstruktive Zusammenarbeit auch und
gerade aus der Opposition heraus nicht
nur eine staatstragende Geste meine
Damen und Herren sondern unser aller
Pflicht denn es geht um viel es geht um
die Zukunft unseres Landes es geht um
die Zukunft unseres Arbeitsmarktes
unserer Wirtschaft und es geht um
unseren Wohlstand
es gab Zeiten da standen
Haushaltsdebatten nicht so Mittelpunkt
des öffentlichen Interesses heute ist
das aus besagten Gründen anders viele
Menschen haben Existenzängste sorgen
sich vor der nächsten Nebenkosten und
Stromabrechnung viele Menschen fürchten
um ihren Arbeitsplatz oder um Ihr
Unternehmen und wir dürfen doch nicht
eine Sekunde vergessen wer dies
verschuldet hat es ist Putin der sein
abscheulichen Krieg weiter fortführt und
das ist Putin der seine Energiepolitik
ganz gezielt gegen uns einsetzt
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger Erwarten doch
zu Recht dass wir Ihnen Sicherheit
bieten dazu hat die Bundesregierung am
vergangenen Wochenende bereits das
dritte Entlastungspaket beschlossen und
das hat es wirklich in sich und auch
für den uns ein Haushalt aufzustellen
der diese geforderte Sicherheit
finanziell ermöglicht wir lassen
niemanden alleine mit seinen
Herausforderungen und seinen Ängsten und
wir müssen alle und alles im Blick haben
das ist für mich verantwortungsvolles
Handeln
dem Einzelplan 11 kommt dabei wieder
eine besondere Bedeutung zu der aktuelle
Entwurf sieht Ausgaben in Höhe von 163
Milliarden Euro vor das ist eine hohe
Summe doch wir haben auch viel vor ab 1
Januar werden wir schrittweise das
Bürgergeld einführen und das ist ein
echter Paradigmenwechsel wir starten mit
einem Regelsatz von 500 Euro und wir
erfüllen ja auch nicht nur einfach unser
Versprechen unser Versprechen aus dem
Koalitionsvertrag wir wollen dass diese
Reform ein Erfolg wird und sie wird ein
großer Erfolg vor allem und ganz konkret
für diejenigen die Unterstützung
benötigen um schnell wieder ein Arbeit
zu kommen die Einführung des Bürgergelds
bedeutet eben nicht nur eine
Namensänderung oder Regelsatzerhöhung
Bürgergeld bedeutet unter anderem die
Entfristung des sozialen Arbeitsmarktes
mehr gezielte Weiterbildung und vor
allen Dingen
individualisierte Betreuung auf
Augenhöhe mit liebe meine Damen und
Herren
und genau dafür benötigen wir genügend
finanzielle Mittel sonst wird der
soziale Arbeitsmarkt einen weiteren
Rückgang erfahren und das können wir uns
nicht leisten wir müssen hier fördern
fördern fördern und das schaffen wir nur
wenn die Jobcenter auch auskömmlich
ausgestaltet sind
seit dem 24 februar sind 100.000
Menschen aus der Ukraine zu uns nach
Deutschland gekommen Putin führt weiter
Krieg gegen die Ukraine und wir müssen
uns darauf einstellen dass diese
Betreuungsleistung umfangreich und vor
allem eine dauerhafte Mehrbelastung für
die Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
Jobcenter bedeutet nur um hier mal eine
Größe einzuordnen vor dem
rechtskreiswechsel ins SGB II im Mai
diesen Jahres wurden von den Jobcentern
3,5 Millionen erwerbsfähige
Leistungsberechtigte betreut nach dem
rechtskreiswechsel der übrigens sehr
zügig und geräuschlos vollzogen wurde
stieg die Zahl im August schon auf 3,8
Millionen und dafür an dieser Stelle
auch mal ein herzlicher Dank an die
Kolleginnen und Kollegen der Jobcenter
für ihre fantastische Arbeit
gemeinsam mit meinen geschätzten
mitberichterstatter Kolleginnen werden
wir in den kommenden Verhandlungswochen
Lösungswege aufzeigen damit wir diesen
Umständen im Gesamtbudget das SGB II
Rechnung tragen und eine auskömmliche
Finanzierung sicherstellen können Willy
Brandt sagte der beste Weg die Zukunft
vorauszusagen ist sie zu gestalten und
gestalten werden wir indem wir mit
diesem Haushalt die wesentlichen
Weichenstellungen vornehmen und
Rahmenbedingungen für den sozialen
Zusammenhalt und ein solidarisch
miteinander setzen das sicherzustellen
ist unsere Verantwortung unsere
gemeinsame Verantwortung denn nur
gemeinsam sind wir stark herzlichen Dank
und Glück auf
vielen Dank Frau Kollege
nächster Redner ist der Kollege Peter
auch mal cdu/cs
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen diese Haushalt
des Bundesministeriums für Arbeit und
Soziales zeigt deutlich dass die
Ampelkoalition Herr Minister an den
Sorgen und Nöten der Menschen in unserem
Land vorbeiregiert
die entlastungspakete
im Frühjahr waren wenig angemessen
sie haben wichtige Teile und zur
Bevölkerung vergessen der Minister
musste das ja heute in seiner Rede ja
eingestehen wir haben von Anfang an
darauf hingewiesen dass die Rentner und
Studenten vergessen haben und bei ihren
stundenlangen Verhandlungen dann
verschiedene Sätze und 300 wer weiß
warum die so zustande gekommen ist
heizen und sein warmes Zuhause brauchen
die einen selbes deswegen ist es gut
dass sie ab und zu auf uns hören und das
wäre beim widmen entlassungspaket
genauso wichtig ein ganzheitliches
Denken Herr Minister und liebe Kollegen
der Ampelkoalition fehlt vollkommen
alleine die Kritik der Verbände wenn man
anschaut kinderreiche Familien fordern
den Ausgleich von Energiekosten ab dem
dritten Kind die Lebenshilfe mahnt an
Nachbesserungen beim Energiepaket für
Menschen mit Behinderung die Werkstätten
hat mir der Wilfried Oellers mit auf den
Weg gegeben für Menschen behindert mit
Behinderung wurden vergessen in Ihrem
Paket und alle bei allen Einzelmaßnahmen
vergessen sie meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren vor die Mittelschicht in
unserem Land ins Auge zu nehmen und
das wäre ein ganz wesentlicher Aspekt
wir haben ja heute angekündigt bekommen
dass es anscheinend einen Schutzschirm
für unsere Unternehmen geben soll wenn
der Schutzschirm genauso verkorkst wird
wie die gasumlage dann wird es
sicherlich eine große Freude für die
Unternehmen in unserem Land meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren eines wird
durch ihre
eines meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren wird durch ihre Politik sehr
deutlich dass sie die Grundprinzipien
der sozialen Marktwirtschaft dass sie
die Grundprinzipien der sozialen
Marktwirtschaft aushöhlen zwei Beispiele
zwei Beispiele hierzu Bundesminister
Habeck und ihre Ampelkoalition meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren nehmen
explizit in kauf ich zitiere ihren
Minister dass es sozialpolitische
Unwuchten geben kann die man dann
irgendwie mal wieder ausgleichen muss
diese Ausgleich meine sehr geehrten
Damen und Herren steht bis heute aus und
Umverteilung ja jahrelang ja also wir
haben auf jeden Fall man könnte
vielleicht in so einer schwierigen Phase
auch mal eingestehen dass man
nachbessert und nicht von unten nach
oben verteilt das Grundprinzip des
unserer Politik auf jeden Fall nicht ist
und die Sie wahrscheinlich auch falsch
auf den Weg bringen dann zum Thema Hartz
IV das durch die SPD die Grünen und die
FDP ja abgeschafft werden soll das ist
denke ich ist eine falsche Reaktion das
ist
also wenn ich die Zitate der SPD
anschaue dann heißt es wir schaffen
Hartz IV ab wenn das nicht wenn das
nicht so also dann ist es ja so also das
ist die falsche Reaktion wenn man den
Arbeitsmarkt anschaut und das so erklärt
sich auch die Äußerung des bayerischen
Ministerpräsidenten wir brauchen eine
aktivierende Arbeitsmarktpolitik da ist
Ausbildung sicherlich ein wesentlicher
Impuls und die leistungsansätze die hier
mit eingebracht werden und wenn man sich
dann sehr geehrter Herr Kurt ihre Rede
anhört mit ihrer gespielten Aufregung
und ihre Fraktionsvorsitzende hat es ja
am Dienstag genauso gemacht dann ist es
tatsächlich etwas Schwieriges dass man
aus meiner Sicht die machen sollte ich
habe gerade gegoogelt ich habe gerade
gegoogelt Diogenes war einer der
provokantesten griechischen Philosophen
die es gab und ich habe ein Zitat von
ihm gefunden das sehr gut auf die
Politik ja gib mir aus der Sonne des
hätte aber jetzt nicht so gut gepasst
sondern ein anderes sehr kurz
nimm mir nicht weg was du mir nicht
geben kannst ich glaube das ist ein
gutes Zitat des der Philosoph die Jugend
ist auf dem Weg gebracht hat genau das
machen sie nicht liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen der Ampel sie nehmen den
Menschen weg lässt das Beispiel und
wissen nicht wie man zurückgeben soll in
so einer schwierigen Zeit deswegen
machen sie eine bessere Politik dass die
Menschen Vertrauen in die Politik der
Koalition finden herzlichen Dank
als nächste Rede eine das Wort die
Kollegin Beate Müller
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident Herr
Minister Kolleginnen und Kollegen wir
beraten den Haushalt und gleichzeitig
arbeiten wir an der zentralen
Arbeitsmarktreform der Ampelkoalition
wir wollen mit dem Bürgergeld ja Herr
Auma wir wollen Hartz IV überwinden und
ein neues System schaffen das auch würde
Augenhöhe und Vertrauen setzen da geht
es natürlich um die soziale Absicherung
aber arbeitslose Menschen brauchen vor
allem auch neue Chancen und Perspektiven
und die entstehen nur durch individuelle
individuelle passende Angebote und
Unterstützung und deshalb werden wir
auch bei der Arbeitsförderung richtig
viel verändern
mit dem
mit dem Bürgergeld werden wir wichtige
Angebote stärken wir werden auch neue
Leistungen einführen beispielsweise ein
Weiterbildungsgeld oder eine
ganzheitliches Coaching mehr
Weiterbildung das schrittweise
Heranführen an den Arbeitsmarkt soziale
Teilhabe all das kostet natürlich Geld
und doch sollen die Mittel um 600
Millionen Euro gekürzt werden und auch
das kritisieren wir denn das würde
gerade den sozialen Arbeitsmarkt Treffen
ein erfolgreiches Instrument das
Perspektiven schafft würde da nicht mehr
richtig funktionieren und es darf nicht
sein denn wir dürfen die Menschen die
besonders lange keine Arbeit haben nicht
alleine lassen
wir brauchen wir brauchen also eine gute
finanzielle Ausstattung im SGB II und
dafür gibt es auch gute Gründe wir
brauchen die Mittel weil jede
Weiterbildung jede Qualifizierung neue
Chancen schaffen es gibt die geflüchtete
Menschen aus der Ukraine sie sind schon
angesprochen worden die zu den
Jobcentern gewechselt sind und die
müssen jetzt qualifiziert werden damit
sie eben nicht im System hängen bleiben
und außerdem haben wir ja noch den
Arbeitskräftemangel und die Antwort
darauf sind eben nicht Sanktionen wie
Herr Merz und die Union immer wieder
vorschlagen die Antworten auf die
Arbeitskräfte Mangel sind Unterstützung
Ausbildung Weiterbildung und
Qualifizierung
und an dieser Stelle zu sparen wäre also
absurd denn es ist immer teurer wenn
Menschen im Bürgergeld feststecken
anstatt sie zu unterstützen und sinnvoll
zu qualifizieren und deshalb dürfen die
Mittel im SGB II nicht gekürzt werden
der eingliederungsetat muss im Gegenteil
sogar gestärkt werden und wenn das mit
der Schuldenbremse und wenn das mit der
Schuldenbremse nicht möglich ist dann
müssen wir eben uns fragen ob diese
Schuldenbremse heute noch in die Zeit
passt das Bürgergeld mit seinem Konzept
darf nicht nur auf dem Papier stehen es
muss gerade jetzt in der schwierigen
Zeit auch tatsächlich bei den Menschen
ankommen und dafür werden wir uns
engagiert einsetzen vielen Dank
Beate Müller Gemmeke war das für Bündnis
90 die Grünen und auf sie folgten und
Ulrike Schielke Ziesing sie sitzt für
die afd-fraktion im Haushaltsausschuss
und auch im Ausschuss für Arbeit und
Soziales
herr Präsident liebe Kollegen verehrte
Bürger ganz europa steckt knietief in
der Krise aber wenn wir einen Blick
hinter die Grenzen werfen dann stellen
wir fest andere Länder kommen damit
besser zurecht das war so während der
Pandemie und das ist auch jetzt so wenn
es darum geht die Folgen des
ukraine-krieges zu bewältigen das alles
müsste nicht sein denn das Elend ist
hausgemacht nach ihrer kopflosen
corona-politik zwingen sie nun mit ihrer
irrsinnigen Energiewende eine ganze
Industrienation in die Knie entgegen
aller Vernunft und Notwendigkeit die
sozialen Folgen nehmen Sie billigend in
Kauf die viertgrößte Industrienation der
Welt ist nicht mehr in der Lage für
grundlegendste Bedürfnisse der Bürger zu
sorgen für Strom Wasser und Wärme
stattdessen debattieren sie allen
Ernstes über zentrale wärmehallen und
geben übergriffige Ratschläge zu
Körperhygiene es ist gut dass sie nun
endlich Geld in die Hand nehmen um
zumindest hier und da die allerhöchste
Not zu lindern doch das reicht hinten
vorne nicht ein großer Teil der
Entlastung sind ja lediglich
überschaubare Einmalzahlungen oder
temporärer Verzicht auf weitere
Belastungen die sie den Bürgern nur
etwas später zumuten wollen siehe
co2-umlage ihre Aufgabe als Regierung
ist es aber für bezahlbare Energie zu
sagen und die Ursachen der Inflation zu
bekämpfen dann bräuchte es auch keine
entlastungspakete für die sie den
Bürgern das Geld vorher aus der Tasche
gezogen haben warum erzähle ich das weil
sich all diese krassen politischen
Fehlentscheidungen im fatalsterweise auf
den Arbeitsmarkt und damit auch auf die
sozialen Sicherungssysteme auswirken die
Zeiten in der die Regierung sämtliche
Probleme mit Geld zuschütten konnte dass
sie zuvor die Mittelstand abkräfte sind
endgültig vorbei nur sie haben das noch
nicht verstanden es sind ja vor allem
deutsche Unternehmen die unter den
horrenden steuernabgaben Umweltauflagen
und jetzt auch noch den explodierenden
Energiekosten leiden Großkonzerne können
ihre Produktion ins Ausland lagern und
das tun sie auch unsere
mittelständischen Unternehmen können das
nicht das Ergebnis für viele Betriebe
rentiert sich die Produktion nicht mehr
viele Menschen werden deshalb nicht nur
in Kurzarbeit gehen sondern ihre Arbeit
ganz verlieren im Einzelplan 11 über den
wir heute reden findet sich übrigens
nichts davon gerade einmal 200 Millionen
Euro zusätzlich sind vor ALG2 und
Heizkosten eingeplant das reicht hinten
und vorne nicht
auf meiner Sommertour durch meinen
Wahlkreis erzählte mir eine Verkäuferin
dass sie sich überlegt ihren Job an den
Nagel zu hängen weil sie jetzt nicht
mehr weiß wie sie das alles bezahlen
soll ihr graut vor dem Winter aber mit
Hartz IV würde der Staat wenigstens fürs
Wohnen und die Heizung sorgen das heißt
wir sind in Deutschland tatsächlich so
weit dass sich die Menschen selbst das
Arbeiten nicht mehr leisten können auf
dieser Art werden Millionen Arbeitnehmer
entmutigt und zu almosenempfängern
degradiert wollen sie das wer wird dann
noch die Steuern und die Beiträge
erwirtschaften um das hausgemachte Elend
ihrer Politik zu lindern im Sinne der
Nachhaltigkeit müssten sie nun
eigentlich alles dafür tun um mehr
Menschen in Arbeit zu bekommen aber das
tun sie nicht bekanntermaßen sind
derzeit rund 2,5 Millionen Menschen
arbeitslos in unserem Land gleichzeitig
war noch nie so viele Stellen unbesetzt
es fehlen vor allem Facharbeiter aber
auch für einfache Hilfstätigkeiten
findet sich kaum jemand mehr ich frage
mich ob es in dieser Situation Situation
eine gute Idee ist die Leistung für die
Eingliederung Langzeitarbeitsloser um
600 Millionen Euro zu kürzen und auf
diese Frage muss erlaubt sein wie ist es
möglich dass nach Jahren der
kostspieligen integrations- und der
Sprachförderung und Ausbildung von
Millionen Zuwanderern anscheinend
niemand in der Lage ist am Flughafen
Koffer zu sortieren oder in der
Gastronomie aufzuhelfen die einzige
Antwort ist dass ihr sämtliche
Steuerungssysteme versagen und
Fehlanreize wirken die nun auch noch
zementiert werden sollen in dem sich das
geplante Bürgergeld zunehmend als
Einstieg in das bedingungslose
Grundeinkommen entpuppt liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn sich nicht
mehr lohnt dann können wir hier im Land
das Licht ausmachen das gilt im übrigen
auch für die Altersvorsorge Millionen
Menschen müssen derzeit zusehen wie ihre
Sparpläne und Betriebsrenten täglich
weniger wert sind hier werden ganze
Lebensplanungen ruiniert wir werden eine
neue Wälder der Altersarmut erleben auch
das ist eine Folge ihrer Politik umso
wichtiger sollte es sein die gesetzliche
Rente zu stabilisieren aber im
haushaltswurf kann ich die dafür
gesetzlich vorgesehenen 500 Millionen
Euro nicht finden und auch die
vollmüller vollmundig angekündigten 10
Milliarden Euro als Einstieg in die
Kapital gedeckte Ergänzung zur
umlagenfinanzierung der Rente fehlen das
ist keine vorausschauende Politik
sondern eine
Kapitulationserklärung vor der Zukunft
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen so kann
das nicht weitergehen ich appelliere an
Sie von den ampelparteien wachen sie auf
befreien Sie unser Land aus dem
Würgegriff der Selbstzerstörung und
ihrer ideologisch fehlgeleiteten Politik
vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin schicke
Ziesing
das Wort erhält nunmehr der Kollege Jens
Beeck FDP-Fraktion
[Applaus]
Sprecher seiner Fraktion
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident lieber Herr
Minister meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren Kolleginnen und Kollegen sie von
der Opposition auch bei uns der ein oder
andere hat noch einen Wunsch das ist uns
sozialpolitikern immer nennt wir haben
immer noch eine gute Idee wo wir etwas
mehr machen könnten aber wenn ich den
Blick noch mal auf das Lenken darf was
heute hier diskutiert wird nämlich der
jetzige Haushalt mit
163,3 Milliarden Euro im ersten Entwurf
dann ist das über ein Drittel mehr als
noch vor zehn Jahren oder umgekehrt vor
zehn Jahren als Basis ist es 50 Prozent
mehr es könnte mal sagen ja gab
Inflation alles ist teurer geworden es
ist auch der Anteil am Gesamthaushalt
des Bundes mit
36,6 Prozent der größte den wir je
hatten und daran erkennen Sie die
Ernsthaftigkeit dieser
fortschrittskoalition im Bereich des
Sozialstaates Geld einzusetzen um zu
Verbesserungen zu kommen und da sind wir
uns sehr einig und wir legen mit diesem
Haushaltsentwurf gewaltig vor meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren da gibt es
eine Vielzahl von Themen
sie können ja sagen was daran falsch ist
wir können das Diskutieren machen und
Faktencheck also es ist der größte
Anteil den wir jemals hatten das machen
wir als SPD Grüne fdp-koalition und das
zeigt die Ernsthaftigkeit die wir hier
haben ich sage das noch mal an dieser
Stelle und die Aufgaben sind in der Tat
riesig und Sie haben Recht der Kollege
grün ich hätte mir auch gewünscht dass
sie 10 Milliarden schon drin sind aber
das wir in der Rente die Aufgabe haben
für alle BezieherInnen das System zu
sichern und das dafür ein Kapital
gedeckter Stock der richtige Weg ist da
sind wir uns doch einig und wenn Sie
sehen dass
ich rede auch gerne mit Ihnen lieber
Kollege matthiasw Birkweiler mit dem
Kollegen grün gerade hatte ich aber
ausdrücklich gesagt und dass ich nicht
alle eins machen
an vielen Reden hier hat man erkennen
die sich gar nicht so richtig auf den
Haushalt des BMAS kapriziert haben dass
wir verschiedene Krisen in diesem Land
zu bewältigen haben und das sorgt auch
dafür dass man einen
koalitionsvertraglich in der
Geschwindigkeit abarbeiten kann wie man
sich das wünschen würde aber es ist eine
Frage der Generationengerechtigkeit dass
wir das machen und wir haben das
vereinbart und wir werden das machen und
angesprochen wurden ist die
bürgergeldreform
auch dafür das sind die nächsten
26 28 Prozent ich sehe mal weniger im
Haushalt auch dafür nehmen wir richtig
Geld in die Hand und es sind Dinge die
wir alle gemeinsam immer schon wussten
dass es eine Vielzahl von Bürokratie
gibt die erstens die Zielgenauigkeit
verhindert von Leistungen die wir im
Bereich ALG2 auch sgb12 erbringen die
verhindert dass es transparent und
nachvollziehbar also verstehbar ist für
diejenigen die
Leistungserbringer sind und für
diejenigen die leistungsberechtigte sind
ich behaupte nach wie vor ich kriege
wenig Widerspruch niemand kann in der
komplexen Situation den Hartz IV Satz so
richtig genau auf den Cent ausrechnen
und das wollen wir ändern durch
Entbürokratisierung der Minister hat es
angesprochen um es nachvollziehbarer zu
machen um es einfacher zu machen
übrigens auch um unsere Verwaltungen zu
entlasten die damit überlastet sind und
am Ende zu einer Verbesserung der
Leistungen zu kommen indem wir das Geld
einsetzen für diejenigen die es brauchen
und nicht für unsere Bürokratie auch das
haben wir uns vorgenommen und das tun
und das hat übrigens etwas mit Würde zu
tun denn jeder der wie viele von uns im
Sozialrecht anwaltlich oder sonst
gearbeitet hat kennt auch diese Fragen
die am Ende aufkommen mit mal 18 Monate
die Kontoauszüge vorlegen mit der Frage
wie liebt man eigentlich in welcher
Konstellation mit wem zusammen das alles
brauchen wir nicht wenn wir es schaffen
leistungsgerechte zum Teil pauschalierte
aber jedenfalls zielgenaue ohne auf die
Intimsphäre der Betroffenen abstillende
Fragen zu kommen Leistungen zu kreieren
das nehmen wir uns vor und das wäre ein
Riesenfortschritt in diesem Land meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren jetzt
habe ich eigentlich gar nicht so viel
über das gesprochen nur weil ich
eigentlich reden wollte nämlich über
Inklusion das ist immer so das Problem
auch das lieber Hubertus Heil ist ja
Kern des Haushalts im BMAS und
Kernaufgabe im Bundesministerium
tatsächlich bleiben ja kaum zwei Prozent
freie Spitze trotzdem wachsen die Mittel
in diesem Jahr auf von 504
Millionen Euro auch an dieser Stelle
zeigen wir dass wir vieles Vorhaben ich
bin sehr überzeugt davon dass wir bei
dem assistenzhundegesetz der
gesetzlichen Verankerung noch im Jahr
2023 erste Vorschritte sogar im Jahr
2022 noch deutlich weiter kommen wir
werden Inklusion durch Sport in dieser
Gesellschaft ganz anders aufstellen als
das bisher der Fall gewesen ist da geht
es gar nicht immer nur um Haushalt
tierisch Unterlegung sondern darum die
Initiativen dies an vielen Stellen schon
gibt mein Kreissportbund im Emsland ist
da vorbildlich das werden wir fördern
und wir werden dafür sorgen dass diese
selbstverständliche Teilhabe in der
Gesellschaft weiterkommt und deswegen
hier Minister wir freuen uns sehr auf
die Aufgaben die wir haben das wird
nicht immer ganz einfach in der
Diskussion aber uns ein das gemeinsame
Ziel und wir werden da vorbeikommen
letzte Ersatz ich freue mich sehr dass
andere Ministerien das mittlerweile auch
erkannt hat im Bundesministerium für
digitales und Verkehr ist heute
empathie-tag stattgefunden und der ist
überschrieben mit Barrieren müssen weg
genau das machen wir gemeinsam auch in
diesem Haus herzlichen Dank für die
Hochzeit
Jens Beek hat gesagt dass man als
Sozialpolitiker immer noch einen Wunsch
habe was man besser machen könnte aber
hat dann doch insgesamt sehr viel
Zustimmung zu diesem
etat-entwurf gezeigt und nächste
Rednerin ist Jessica tatisi Sprecherin
für Arbeitsmarktpolitik der
Linksfraktion
Präsident Kolleginnen und Kollegen Herr
Minister sie loben sich ja selbst am
meisten für das geplante Bürgergeld
Beratung auf Augenhöhe mehr Mitsprache
von Arbeitslosen auf ihrem Weg zurück in
Arbeit mehr Wertschätzung für die
Beschäftigten in den Jobcentern aber wo
findet sich das im Haushalt sehen wir
uns die Verwaltungskosten der Jobcenter
an die Jobcenter haben 2021 fast sechs
Milliarden Euro für ihre Verwaltung
gebraucht aber sie starten Sie für das
kommende Jahr nur mit fünf Milliarden
aus also gleich viele Hartz-IV-Empfänger
sollen besser beraten werden mit einer
Milliarde weniger das kann nicht
hinhauen die fehlende Milliarde müssen
sich die Jobcenter woanders holen und
sie können Sie sich nur bei den
eingliederungsmitteln holen also aus dem
Topf der dazu da ist Menschen wieder in
Arbeit zu bringen Minister Heim mit
ihrer Planung zwingen sie die Jobcenter
sie zwingen sie genau das auch zu tun
die Gelder fehlen dann bei beruflichen
Weiterbildungen und sie fehl bei anderen
Förderungen wie dem sozialen
Arbeitsmarkt und dann kürzen Sie die
eingliederungsmittel nochmal um über 600
Millionen Euro also das ist doch absurd
mitnehmen sie den Menschen in Hartz IV
auch noch die letzte Hoffnung auf einen
Job noch dazu wollen sie die Leute mit
einer mini-erhöhung der Regelsätze und
gerade mal 50 Euro abspeisen inmitten
der krassesten Inflation und das auch
erst ab Januar warum das erhöhen sie
doch die Regelsätze einfach jetzt
die Wahrheit ist während SPD und Grüne
von Augenhöhe Respekt und Würde reden
opfern sie eiskalt die Gelder für
Arbeitslose der Schuldenbremse was die
Schuldenbremse angeht sind Hubertus Heil
und Christian Lindner ein Herz und eine
Seele
Kolleginnen und Kollegen alle Zahlen
zeigen die Jobcenter haben bereits
vorsorglich mit dem Sparen begonnen
Weiterbildungen und geförderte
Arbeitsplätze werden nur noch zögerlich
vergeben die Förderzahlen sinken sie
sparen den sozialen Arbeitsmarkt kaputt
eine Förderung für die sie sich haben
feiern lassen Minister Heil das ist
nicht der versprochene respekt das ist
eine verdammt miese Politik auf dem
Rücken von Arbeitslosen
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin
Wolfgang kopitty Kubicki
Bundestagsvizepräsident hört man hier
immer schon wenn die Rednerinnen und
Redner zu lange sprechen dann klopft er
immer ganz gern anders Pult mit mehr
oder weniger Erfolg dass diese dann ihre
Rede schnell beenden
verehrter Herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren unsere
Gesellschaft hat es mit großen
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
Herausforderungen zu tun die Explosion
des Gaspreises der generelle Anstieg der
Energiepreise und als Folge die
rekordinflation
und die Regierung und der Bundeskanzler
Olaf Scholz handelt seit Monaten werden
Alternativen zu russischem Gas
vorangebracht und mit zwei
entlastungspaketen wurden die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger um insgesamt rund
30 Milliarden Euro entlastet und in
dieser Woche hat die Ampelkoalition das
dritte Entlastungspaket vereinbart
dieses dritte Entlastungspaket ist ein
großer Wurf mit 65 Milliarden ist es
doppelt so groß wie die beiden ersten
zusammen damit geben wir fast 100
Milliarden Euro aus um die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger zu entlasten
dieses
jede Entlastungspaket ist aber auch
mutig weil es in die Preisbildung auf
den Energiemärkten eingreift um
sicherzustellen dass der Grundbedarf an
Strom und heizen für Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und Unternehmen wieder bezahlbar
wird und das Entlastungspaket ist
zielgerichtet und sozial ausgewogen denn
es profitieren Rentner und Studierende
die Arbeiten der Mitte Geringverdiener
und Bürgerinnen und Bürger die auf
Grundsicherung angewiesen sind unsere
Botschaft heißt Deutschland Takt das und
zwar solidarisch wir lassen niemanden
allein
ich finde
finde schon bemerkenswert dass wir heute
für sozialpolitische Ratschläge von der
Union wieder bekommen haben ich kann nur
sagen für mich ist das nicht glaubwürdig
ich erinnere mich gut an die letzten
acht Jahre große Koalition ja liebe
Hermann grüß war nicht alles schlecht
aber jeder sozialpolitische Fortschritt
musste mit Mühe gegen sie gegen euch
durchgesetzt werden und
nein ich frag mich auch wie glaubwürdig
ist es sie sind doch die Partei die will
dass das Solidaritätszuschlag auch noch
für die obersten fünf Prozent
abgeschafft wird sie sind doch die
Partei die hier im Mindestlohn von 12
Euro nicht zugestimmt hat und sie sind
doch die Partei die sich als wir in der
letzten Wahlperiode in der
rentenkommission über die Zukunft der
Rente gesprochen haben nicht bereit war
dazu zu bekennen dass wir das
Rentenniveau dauerhaft sichern
also
seien Sie mal ganz ganz ruhig an der
Stelle meine Damen und Herren dieses
Entlastungspaket bietet Antworten auf
die ganz akuten Handlungsbedarfe in
dieser Krise
daneben bleiben aber auch grundsätzliche
Herausforderungen für den Arbeitsmarkt
und den sozialen Zusammenhalt in
Deutschland und auch die packen wir an
zum Beispiel die Ungerechtigkeiten auf
dem Arbeitsmarkt und lohndarm den ich
will nur mal daran erinnern dass in drei
Wochen am 1 Oktober der Mindestlohn auf
12 Euro steigt
das ist Respekt meine Damen und Herren
zum Beispiel das Thema Fachkräftemangel
der Minister hat es angesprochen
Fachkräftemangel bis hin zum
Arbeitskräftemangel in vielen Branchen
und Regionen unseres Landes und ich bin
sehr dankbar dass die Bundesregierung
gestern ihre fachkräftestrategie auf den
Weg gebracht hat mit zwei großen
Pfeilern nämlich einmal die inländischen
Potenziale zu nutzen durch verschiedene
Maßnahmen von der Verbesserung der
Ausbildung bis hin zur Weiterbildung
aber auch damit dass wir endlich
Einwanderung wirklich in dieses Land
ermöglichen durch ein neues
fachkräfteeinwanderungsgesetz
und
das nächste große Projekt dieser
Ampelkoalition ist das Bürgergeld und da
muss ich mich schon sehr wundern also
Jessica Tati sitzt jetzt auch schon eine
Weile hier im Deutschen Bundestag sollte
schon wissen dass als der
Haushaltsentwurf gemacht worden ist
durch die Bundesregierung des
bürgergeldgesetz der Entwurf noch gar
nicht vorlagen das heißt es war noch gar
nicht möglich einzupflegen wie viel Geld
das neue Bürgergeld kosten wird das
werden wir jetzt machen in den
Haushaltsberatungen und werden deswegen
diesen etat-entwurf auf jeden Fall
verändern um das Bürgergeld zu
finanzieren
ja Bürgergeld meine Damen und Herren das
bedeutet höhere Regelsätze rund 500 Euro
ab dem 1 Januar 2023 dazu brauche ich
aber ein Gesetz Frau tat die eingesetzt
bei euch ich kann nur hier nicht
gesetzlos irgendwie sofort den Leuten
Geld geben ich backe ein Gesetz wir
leben doch in einem Rechtsstaat zum
ersten ersten 23
500 Euro so aber aber meine Damen und
Herren es geht um mehr als um Regelsätze
es geht um die größte
arbeitsmarktpolitische und
sozialpolitische Reform es geht um einen
Kulturwandel es geht um die Anerkennung
von Lebensleistungen ein einfacheren
Zugang und Beratung auf Augenhöhe um ein
anderes Verhältnis von Bürger und Staat
auch das ist eine Frage von Respekt
keiner soll sich schämen wenn er auf
diese Hilfe angewiesen ist
vor allem
vor allem aber geht es um bessere
individuelle Beratung und Unterstützung
damit mehr Langzeitarbeitslose den Weg
in nachhaltige Beschäftigung ermöglicht
wird damit der Arbeitsmarkt
durchlässiger inklusiver wird und wir
damit auch ein Beitrag leisten um
Fachkräftemangel zu bekämpfen und
deshalb da geht es im Kern darum die
Arbeitgeber die suchen und die
Langzeitarbeitslosen besser
zusammenzubringen meine Damen und Herren
deshalb setzen wir auf mehr
Weiterbildung und Anreize dafür und was
die Union hier wieder behauptet hat
nämlich dass wir hier an bedingungsloses
Grundeinkommen schaffen wird und dass
wir Sanktionen abschaffen würden und
mitwirkenspflichten wird durch
Wiederholung nicht wahrnehmen
wird selbstverständlich
Mitwirkungspflichten enthalten aber
eines
nein nein also kommt die kommen jetzt
wieder zum Schluss machen wir nicht wir
werden nicht
diese Mehrheit von über 90%
noch einmal ich kann nicht
es wird keiner mehr ist glauben Sie mir
das einfach
wenn wir uns dran gewöhnen dass wir
überall die Redezeiten einhalten also
bei der AFD und anderen dann bitte auch
selbst ich finde es nicht mehr fair dass
über 30 Sekunden überzogen wird
nächste Rednerin ist die Kollegin Jana
Schimke cdu/csu-fraktion
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
weil wir heute mit so vielen warmen
Worten unseres
bundesarbeitsministers hier begrüßt
wurden will ich doch auch noch mal sagen
lieber Herr Heil die Energiekrise lösen
Sie nicht nur allein mit Sozialpolitik
die Energiekrise lösen Sie indem Sie die
richtigen energiepolitischen
Entscheidungen treffen und dazu und dazu
gehört zum einen zum Beispiel mal alle
Energiereserven zu nutzen die dieses
Land zu bieten hat und ich hätte mir
natürlich auch von einem
sozial und Arbeitsminister gewünscht der
sie ja nun auch einmal sind das ist auch
ein paar Vorschläge gibt wie diese
Unternehmen durch die absolute
mega-krise kommen sollen die uns jetzt
gerade bevorsteht wir wissen alle wir
haben hier im Deutschen Bundestag wurde
12 Euro Mindestlohn eingeführt durch die
Bundesregierung wir haben kürzlich hier
ein Arbeitsbedingungen gesetzt auf die
auf dem Weg gebracht wir haben
selbstverständlich abgelöst und
abgelehnt und sie äußern kein Wort dazu
wie sie eigentlich die Unternehmen vor
diesen Belastungen schützen wollen ich
wundere mich immer wieder auch über die
Einschätzung aus diversen Reihen liebe
Frau raffelhüchen wenn sie sagen die
Betriebe schließen jetzt vorübergehend
sagen sie doch nicht sowas sie wissen
ganz genau dass das nicht der Fall ist
das konnten sie vielleicht noch in der
corona-krise erzählen wo es dem Land
noch relativ gut ging wo die Kassen noch
voll waren wo wir uns diese ganzen
Programme noch leisten konnten aber es
ist kein Geld mehr da auch bei den
Unternehmen ist kein Geld mehr die
schließen nicht vorübergehend die
schließen für immer und das was
Wirtschaftsminister Habig gesagt hat
Anschlag ins Gesicht in den gesamten
deutschen Mittelstand deswegen sparen
Sie sich solche Äußerungen so und was
wir in diesem Haushalt sehen ist viel
beschrieben worden in dieser Debatte
letztendlich ist vieles was geplant ist
gar nicht im Haushalt enthalten und das
was in Corona einmalig beschlossen wurde
wo wir als Union auch mitgemacht haben
zu sagen okay wir setzen die
vermögensprüfung aus okay wir machen
Verbesserungen beim Kurzarbeitergeld
wird jetzt einfach mal sofort geführt
ohne zu überlegen ob das eigentlich die
richtigen Maßnahmen sind die Kosten der
Unterkunft werden massiv steigen in
diesem Land durch die steigenden
Energiepreise ist im Haushalt nicht
abgebildet wir werden Steigerungen bei
den Kosten der Grundsicherung haben wenn
durch den Regelsatz ist auch nicht
abgebildet wir werden so planen Sie es
ja auch die aktienrente einführen ist
ebenfalls nicht im Haushalt enthalten
und das Problem ist sie setzen völlig
falsche Prioritäten sie setzen völlig
falsche Prioritäten in ihrer Politik mit
dem Bürgergeld führen sie Brücken aus
Beschäftigung statt in Beschäftigung und
ich sage es hier noch einmal sie führen
rahmenbedingungsloses Grundeinkommen ein
das ist die Vorstufe zu dem was darauf
kommen wird und sie verabschieden sich
sie verabschieden sich endgültig vom
aktivierenden Sozialstaat vieles ist ja
leider schon in der Vergangenheit
geschehen es geht weiter und lieber Herr
Koth lieber Herr Kurt da wir hier
ständig über das Thema Menschenbild
reden und welches Bild wir denn
eigentlich tatsächlich haben ich will
mal daran erinnern dass wir eine Menge
getan haben in den letzten Legislaturen
um bedürftige Menschen in Deutschland zu
unterstützen wir sind die letzten die
uns von ihnen unterstellen lassen wir
hätten kein soziales Gewissen
aber lieber Herr Kurt und auch wenn Sie
jetzt gleich Schnappatmung kriegen ich
will sie trotzdem mit einer mit einem
Brief konfrontieren den einen Jobcenter
bekommen hat von einem sogenannten
Kunden in dem nämlich drin steht für die
Dauer des sanktionsmotoriums bitte ich
von Vermittlungsangeboten abzusehen so
meine Damen und Herren und Sie können
uns hier unterstellen dass wir hier
irgendwelche Märchen erzählen aber das
ist nicht der Fall solche Fälle gibt es
tatsächlich und was sagen sie denn den
vielen Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern
in den Jobcentern die seit vielen Jahren
eine hervorragende Arbeit leisten und
sich jetzt eben solche Sprüche anhören
müssen und was soll eigentlich diese
sechs Monate vertrauenszeit wir wissen
alle vertrauen ist gut Kontrolle ist
besser wofür sollen denn die Menschen
eigentlich bewahrt und geschützt werden
warum geht es hier darum jemanden
schrittweise in den Arbeitsmarkt zu
integrieren wofür soll der denn
geschützt werden Arbeit ist doch nicht
schlimmes das tut doch nicht weh das ist
doch gut ich würde mir wünschen dass wir
hier deutlich andere Vorgehensweise
wählen vielen Dank
Diana Schimke war das und meine Damen
und Herren sie sehen dass wir auch nach
Schottland schauen aus Großbritannien
gab es die beunruhigende Nachrichten
dass es um die Gesundheit von Queen
Elizabeth der zweiten nicht gut steht
deswegen schauen wir auch nach
Schottland
liebe Bürgerinnen und Bürger wir haben
heute jetzt schon einiges gehört zum
Thema Fachkräfte und Weiterbildung und
Sie liebe Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger
sind der Motor der Antrieb für uns und
genau aus diesem Grund muss die
Weiterbildung die fachkräftestrategie
breit und ressortübergreifend
aufgestellt sein und das ist sie so
vielfältig wie unsere Gesellschaft ist
unsere Arbeitswelt aber wie funktioniert
so eine Strategie nehmen wir mal eine
Uhr eine Armbanduhr als Beispiel Liebe
uhrmacherinnen und Uhrmacher verzeihen
Sie mir für eventuelle fachliche Fehler
jetzt in der Ausführung des folgenden
Beispiels aber wenn es um Präzision geht
passt das uhrmacherinnen Handwerk
einfach hervorragend und Präzision
brauchen wir hier wir bringen die Uhr
hier als Synonym für die Strategie zum
Laufen der Bedarf am Fachkräften dreht
an der Krone also er rüttelt eigentlich
schon richtig und das bringt die
Spiralfeder die Zahnräder in Schwung
wir als ampelregierung montieren diese
Zahnräder mit gezielten Maßnahmen mit
verschiedenen Handwerkszeug wie zum
Beispiel die weiterbildungsplattform die
Stärkung der weiterbildungsverbünde das
bringt die Menschen verschiedene
Möglichkeiten näher und ein Zahnrad wird
auch gezielt für die Vereinbarkeit von
Familie und Weiterbildung Beruf
eingebaut werden und
das wird dann auf das Ziffernblatt
übertragen und zwar für alle sichtbar
mit wo gibt's was was kann ich machen
was gibt es überhaupt und wo wird es
gebrauchen wir müssen raus aus dem
Dschungel wir brauchen keinen Dschungel
sondern ein kurzes schnelles suchen und
dann finden
Fachkräfte
Arbeitskräfte aus nah und fern halten
unsere Arbeitswelt am laufen sie bringen
uns alle voran die Fachkraft die
Arbeitskraft für morgen wird jetzt
ausgebildet und jetzt weitergebildet und
ein wichtiger Punkt ist die
Weiterbildungsmöglichkeit die
Weiterbildung eben für alle zugänglich
zu machen und dieses Zahnrad setzen wir
auch in dieser Uhr ein flexibles Zahnrad
das für uns alle die Möglichkeit des
weiterkommens bietet die Arbeitswelt ist
im Wandel so wie schon immer war aber
die Uhr läuft jetzt schneller sie läuft
anders wir müssen handeln espressiert
und das tun wir mit Ihnen liebe
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger den
Fachkräften von heute und dem
Fachkräften von morgen und übermorgen
und dafür stellen wir das Handwerkszeug
mit diesen Haushalt als Auftakt
dankeschön
Tina Winkelmann war das für Bündnis 90
die Grünen auf sie folgt Stefan Stracke
der Sprecher für Arbeit und Soziales der
Unionsfraktion
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren Inflation macht arm
und hohe Inflation macht schnell ab und
das trifft vor allem diejenigen die es
bereits eh schon schwer haben das sind
die Geringverdiener die gar keinen Job
haben aber das betrifft auch die Breite
arbeitende Mitte dieser Gesellschaft und
deswegen zeichnet sich gute
Sozialpolitik immer dadurch aus dass sie
auf Preisstabilität achtet und auch eine
gute Wirtschaftspolitik macht und das
sind genau die Lehrstellen auch dieser
Koalition wir müssen das Leben für die
Mitte der Gesellschaft bezahlbar halten
in diesen Bereichen und ihr
Entlastungspaket das kommt zunächst
einmal wuchtig daher
es kommt aber zu spät und es wirkt zu
spät
viele der angekündigten Entlastungen
greifen erst zum Jahresende 2022 kommen
vielleicht erst 23 mitten in der kalten
Jahreszeit und bis dahin explodieren die
Kosten weiter und überholen die
Entlastungen bevor sie überhaupt gewährt
werden und natürlich ist es richtig und
es war auch überfällig dass sie jetzt
Rentnerinnen und Rentner und auch die
Studierenden in das Entlastungspaket mit
aufnehmen was die energiepreispauschale
angeht sie haben diese aber ja bewusst
ausgenommen gehabt in ihren vorherigen
entlastungspaketen darauf haben wir
immer wieder hingewiesen sie korrigieren
das jetzt das erkennen wir ausdrücklich
an und natürlich ist es bei diesen
Preissteigerungen die wir auf dem
Energiemarkt haben richtig auf dem Thema
verfügbarkeit und Preis zu achten gerade
was die Energiekosten angeht und die
Energie und deswegen ist es falsch
gerade was das Thema Verfügbarkeit
angeht ganz bewusst Kapazitäten aus dem
Markt heraus zu und genau das tun sie
mit der Atomenergie weil dieser
Bundesminister der Wirtschaft nicht dazu
sich hat durchreden können und diese
Koalition macht es mit dass die
Arbeitskräfte das jetzt die Atomkraft
beispielsweise in der Reserve geschickt
wird
Michael Vassiliadis hat eine andere
Haltung da dazu im Deutschlandfunk sagt
er wir brauchen alles an
Stromkapazitäten was wir zur Verfügung
haben und zwar bis 2024 und wo er recht
hat hat er recht weil er genau weiß was
das bedeutet auch für die Arbeitsplätze
in Deutschland bei der strompreisbremse
vollkommen unklar in welcher Höhe und
wann diese denn tatsächlich kommt also
die Entlastungen schreiben Sie auf aber
Sie sind vollkommen unklar wann diese
tatsächlich kommen und beim Gas das ist
doch die größte Lehrstelle die Sie in
diesem Entlastungspaket haben 20
Millionen Menschen und viele Unternehmen
lassen sie alleine bei diesem Thema der
Gasentwicklung und es kommt ja noch
hinzu mit der gasumlage belasten sie ja
noch zusätzlich die Haushalte dazu das
passt alles nicht zusammen und es ist ja
richtig Herr Bundesminister um jeden
Arbeitsplatz zu kämpfen
aber die Preissteigerung kommen an auch
bei dem Mittelstand bei der
Mittelschicht und der arbeitenden
Bevölkerung und wenn die Insolvenzgefahr
steigt dann ist es richtig dass wir auch
das Thema Kurzarbeit als Instrument
verlängern nur gleichzeitig muss man
dann auch sagen der Bundesminister dann
müssen wir auch über die notwendigen
Mittel reden und nicht nur alleine auf
Darlehen abgehen sondern das dann auch
auf Zuschüsse ansonsten haben wir
letztendlich mit Zitronen gehandelt weil
die ist nur zu weiteren Belastungen für
Unternehmer und für die Beitragszahler
führt da besteht noch Handlungsbedarf in
diesem Bereich
und wir wollen natürlich auch das
Langzeitarbeitslose
wieder Fuß fassen gerade auch nach der
corona-krise und da brauchen wir von
Ihnen überhaupt keine Nachhilfe Bedarf
denn wir haben in dieser Koalition die
wir mit Angela Merkel über 16 Jahre
hatten waren wir da sehr erfolgreich in
diesem Bereich was den Abbau der
Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit angeht aber sie
sind es doch die jetzt die
Verwaltungskosten bei den Jobcentern
kürzen sie sind es doch die jetzt die
Integrationsleistungen um 600 Millionen
Euro kürzen und das bedeutet im Übrigen
eine Absenkung der integrationsmittel
pro Kopf gegenüber 2019 um 20 Prozent um
20% ist das der Respekt den sie den
Langzeitarbeitslosen gegenüberbringen
wir wollen mehr Chancen aber doch nicht
auf diese Art und Weise dass sie
letztendlich die Mittel für
Langzeitarbeitslose absenkt das ist der
falsche Weg
und für die SPD-Fraktion hat das Frau Dr
Tanja machalet
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen lieber Herr Stracke ich hätte
mir wirklich gewünscht dass sie mehr
Zeit darauf verwenden uns mal zu
erläutern welche Vorstellungen sie im
Hinblick auf den soziale Etat haben also
dass wir jetzt Atomkraftwerke laufen
lassen sollen um die um den sozialitat
zu reduzieren das ist schon eine Volvo
also beachtlich
ja
es wäre trotzdem schön gewesen wenn sie
uns erläutert hätten was welche
Vorstellungen sie im Hinblick auf
unseren Sozialstaat haben das haben sie
nicht getan und ich möchte auch nur
nochmal daran erinnern weil sie sich ja
um die Langzeitarbeitslosigkeit sorgen
es war nicht sie die 16i 16e
vorangetrieben haben den sozialen
Arbeitsmarkt und das waren wir
ja unsere Aufgabe besteht jetzt darin
dafür zu sorgen dass wir durch einen
starken handlungsfähigen Sozialstaat die
Solidarität und die wirtschaftliche
Stabilität in diesem Lande gewährleisten
in diesem schwierigen Zeiten genau dazu
leistet der Einzelplan 11
einen großen Beitrag und wir werden
natürlich das was hier auch eingefordert
haben die Entlastungsmaßnahmen jetzt
schnell auf den Weg bringen ich denke
das ist uns allen klar dass wir das
jetzt tun müssen aber es geht natürlich
auch darum dass wir langfristig die
strukturellen Reformen der
sozialensicherungssysteme angehen das
Bürgergeld ist ein Baustein dafür und da
fällt Ihnen ja auch nur das
sanktionsmoratorium anders haben sie ja
auch jetzt hier ausgeführt aber auch
nicht wie sie sich das Ganze vorstellen
ich möchte aber beim Stichwort
Bürgergeld und auch weil das Thema
Kurzarbeit ja auch eine Rolle gespielt
hat in den Ausführungen des Ministers
und auch bei ihm Herrn starke einfach
nochmal auf die Bundesagentur zur Arbeit
zu sprechen kommen und ich möchte auch
dass also die dass die Herausforderung
vor denen die Bundesagentur für Arbeit
steht und das können wir uns alle
vorstellen wenn es jetzt auch wieder zu
kurzarbeitssituationen kommt dass die
Bundesagentur auch für die entsprechend
dafür entsprechend gewappnet ist und
auch für die kommenden Herausforderungen
auch für das was wir im
Koalitionsvertrag uns vorgenommen haben
nämlich die Weiterentwicklung zur
weiterbildungs- und
qualifizierungsagentur und natürlich
auch dass die Bundesagentur den
Fachkräftebedarf in den eigenen
Organisationen bewältigen kann aber
nichts vor allem darum jetzt auch an
dieser Stelle nochmal weil wir auch
sehen was dort geleistet worden ist im
Hinblick auf die Kurzarbeit möchte an
dieser Stelle einfach noch mal den
Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeitern in der
Bundesagentur dafür ganz ganz herzlich
Danke sagen das war wirklich ganz
hervorragend und wir wissen auch was wir
bauen können wenn wir jetzt eben auch
wieder eine Situation kommen wo wir
Kurzarbeit auszahlen müssen und ich
denke alles in unser aller Sinne dass
wir die Bundesagentur auch an der Stelle
so aufstellen wie wir was so wie wir sie
benötigen das was die Bundesagentur
benötigt und ich könnte jetzt natürlich
auch noch mal darauf hinweisen dass
gerade als rentenpolitikerin mir wichtig
ist dass wir jetzt auch was für die
Rentnerinnen und Rentner auszahlen aber
wichtiger ist fast noch wichtiger ist
dass wir das Signal zum Schluss dass wir
im Herbst das rentenniveausstabilisieren
da bin ich gespannt wie sie sich
verhalten also wir haben noch einiges
vor uns in diesem Haushalt mit diesem
Haushalt und herzlichen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit
der Zugang zur Kurzarbeit ist noch bis
zum Jahresende
vereinfacht das hat hier Tanja machalat
von der SPD noch einmal gewürdigt auf
sie folgt nun sie gelauna
cdu/csu-fraktion
ich packe meine Koffer sie kennen es
sicherlich dieses Kinderspiel weil
welchem jeder der Spiel Teilnehmer
nacheinander anfügt was er gerne in den
Koffer einpacken möchte und ja danach
muss man sich immer mehr Begriffe merken
und dann kommt zu Verwirrungen und
Verwechslungen ja warum erzähle ich
Ihnen das naja weil ich manchmal den
Eindruck habe ehrlich gesagt dass die
aktuelle
Regierungskoalition gerne dieses Spiel
spielt sie packen in den schuldenkoffer
ein was sie gerne hätten die Grünen die
Fortsetzung des neuen euro-tickets die
SPD des Bürgergeld die FDP das zumindest
dank Schattenhaushalte noch
halbwegs so klingende Einhaltung der
Schuldenbremse und dabei übersehen kommt
dann immer noch im Interesse des
koalitionsfriedens das ein oder andere
drauf man will es allen Recht machen die
Schulden werden immer mehr immer
überschaubarer der schuldenkoffer kann
man kaum mehr schieben die nächste
Generation wird es ja erledigen
Herausforderungen sind gewaltig
stehen wieso sie helfen gerade akut
helfen um den Menschen im Moment des
Leben erträglicher zu machen die Kosten
sind immens und viele kommen nicht mehr
über die Runden viele die viel Arbeiten
zählen das Geld kaufen nur noch im
Angebot im Supermarkt ein die Folgen der
corona-pandemie
lieferkettenverzögerungen wir wissen
auch nicht wie sie sind zukünft
entwickelt die Inflation der Ukraine
Krieg insbesondere mit explodierenden
Gas und Strompreisen belasten die
Menschen sehr und ich kenne eigentlich
keinen der sich keine Sorgen macht und
nicht überlegt ob er sich das künftig
alles leisten kann
aber gerade deshalb
aber gerade deshalb ist es so wichtig in
solchen Situationen dass man genau
überlegt dass man wenn man Pakete schürt
schnürt die Geld kosten auch die Folgen
analysiert dass man das Geld effizient
einsetzt ja dass man Prioritäten setzt
und Prioritäten setzen das ist nicht
einfach das schmerzt und wird
Prioritäten setzt der enttäuscht der
enttäuscht den der sich vielleicht mehr
oder was anderes versprochen hat oder
wenn er sieht der andere wird mir
vorgezogen bei der Prioritätensetzung
leider Gottes gehören Enttäuschungen
dazu und es ist nicht so dass wir das
gerne machen nur weil wir irgendjemanden
schaden würden ganz im Gegenteil aber
gerade in solchen Zeiten ich frage mich
wie wollen sie es denn machen wollen Sie
jede paar Monate mit dem Geldkoffer hier
verteilen alle paar Monate gerade in
solchen Zeiten gehört es dazu
einfach Mut zu haben weil man es leider
nicht nur mit Geld verteilen allen recht
machen kann und leider hat der Etat des
aber in Sozialministerium für mich da
keinerlei Anhaltspunkte ich kann diesen
Mut hier nicht ansatzweise irgendwo
erkennen
und klar ja oder das was würden Sie denn
machen das ist nämlich das das ist das
Problem reine riesen Show 65 Milliarden
wir verteilen Geld das aller
allerwichtigste ist natürlich so schwer
es ist genau da anzusehen wo die
Ursachen sind und jetzt muss ich ehrlich
sagen diese große Show für 65 Milliarden
verteilen hätte ich gerne mal da gehabt
wo man uns präsentiert was für
Bemühungen man alles macht um das
Angebot beim Energielieferanten zu
bieten Katar besucht nichts rausgekommen
bei anderen Ländern offensichtlich schon
eine Atomkraft das wollen wir nicht ich
sage nur ideologieoffen
Kohlestrom ihr das schaffen wir mal so
ein bisschen aber ja nicht zu viel also
klar ist wenn wir das Angebot nicht
erhöhen werden wir die Probleme nicht
lösen und es wird nicht funktionieren
dass sie alle zwei Monate Geld verteilen
das Geld haben wir nicht es tut mir leid
ist so zu sagen das schlimme ist aber
das so viel dran hängt und warum
diskutieren wir denn auch leider Gottes
auch hier über die Energie warum ist das
Teil hier auch dieser Debatte weil
natürlich die Menschen genau das Spüren
weil es sich nichts ist sozialer als ob
ein Mensch es sich nicht leisten kann
mehr normal einzukaufen Lebensmittel
oder was seine Wohnung heizen kann wenn
die Wirtschaft leider Gottes sich trank
explodieren der Stromkosten nicht mehr
leisten kann zu produzieren da sind wir
doch im Arbeitsministerium da ist es
gesagt worden was können wir tun die zu
stärken da kommt zu wenig zu wenig für
den Mittelstand und leider die
Beschäftigten werden es merken da sind
wir genau in diesem Etat
und deshalb kann ich Ihnen raten
schmeißen dir die Ideologie ihren Haufen
sie können und wir unterstützen dass die
Transformation weitergeben gehen aber
bitte machen Sie eineinhalb Jahre
Realpolitik und nur das zählt für die
Menschen im Land denn die brauchen Ihre
Unterstützung und keine Ideologie und
Besserwisserei
es gäbe noch so viel zu sagen wir haben
ja zum Glück noch eine zweite und dritte
lese bitte zum Schluss wünsche Ihnen und
uns allen dass es nicht so schlimm wird
wie es inzwischen viele
Wirtschaftsexperten sagen letzter Satz
eine showmante the gelaunert das
Entlastungspaket das dürfte die nächste
und hier die letzte Rednerin in der
Debatte anders sehen Stefanie Effner
spricht jetzt für Bündnis 90 die Grünen
[Applaus]
das ist Teile dieses Hauses hier gibt
die sich darüber freuen wenn es Menschen
noch schlechter geht und das halt
irgendwie dummerweise offenbaren weil
sie vergessen Mikros aufzumachen
zuzumachen nach Debatten geschenkt
passiert aber das andere Teile dieses
Hauses
diese Debatte auf diese Art und Weise
hier heute führen das finde ich der
Angemessenheit in der Lage in der wir
uns befinden überhaupt nicht angemessen
wir befinden uns in einer Krise die den
Menschen so viel Sorgen bereitet wie
noch nie in diesem Land ja ich komme
darauf zurück eben ihr letzter
Redebeitrag redet von Energieeinkauf in
Katar von Atomkraftwerken ich dachte wir
debattieren den Haushalt des bemas an
dieser Stelle und machen uns darüber
Gedanken
also die Leute interessieren
dann
bringen sie
faktenfreie Behauptungen in die Debatte
wie ein bedingungsloses Grundeinkommen
was wir hier einführen würden das sagt
schon eigentlich das Wort bedingungslos
wir haben eigentlich immer noch eine
Bedürftigkeitsprüfung manchmal hilft es
wenn man Gesetzentwürfe über die man
debattiert auch liest bevor man Menschen
hier gegeneinander aufhält
die Menschen erwarten von uns
Lösungsvorschläge und sie dürfen uns
gerne kritisieren aber dann bringen Sie
ernsthaft auch wirklich ihre Vorschläge
in die Debatte ein dann freuen wir uns
auf die Auseinandersetzung dazu wir
brauchen an dieser
drei Dinge ja das haben sie immer wieder
angesprochen wir müssen über die Preise
für Energie reden aber das ist Aufgabe
von anderen Ressorts hier
braucht müssen wir darüber reden wie wir
die Folgen des russischen Angriffs
Krieges
sozialabfedern an dieser Stelle und
genau deshalb ist es so wichtig dass die
soziale Frage in diesem Haushaltsentwurf
eben beantwortet wird und wir jetzt
aktuell mit der bürgergeldreform
gleichzeitig an einer
riesenreform in diesem Bereich arbeiten
Kollege Rosemann hat es gesagt die
Aufgaben die wir uns mit der
bürgergeldreform gestellt haben die sind
noch nicht abgebildet im
Haushaltsentwurf der das war ja noch gar
nicht fertig und auch die Entscheidung
des entlastungspaketes vom letzten
Wochenende sind eben noch nicht da drin
und genau das wird jetzt Aufgabe des
parlamentarischen Verfahrens sein und ja
unsere Aufgabe ist es Menschen Angst zu
nehmen denn zu Freiheit gehört auch die
Freiheit dazu keine Angst haben zu
müssen wie ich meine Stromrechnung
bezahlen muss und genau das sind
Aufgaben die wir uns im Laufe des
parlamentarischen Verfahrens zum
Bürgergeld stellen müssen wie wir diese
Fragen lösen und da laden wir Sie
herzlich ein mit uns konstruktiv daran
zu arbeiten
das war dann die erste Beratung zum
Einzelplan 11 Arbeit und Soziales von
Bundesminister Hubertus Heil
163,33 Milliarden Euro sind im
Entwurf vorgesehen für das kommende Jahr
um natürlich so große Fragen zu lösen
wie den Fachkräftemangel eine
Altersvorsorge wie die gestaltet werden
kann und auch wie die Grundsicherung für
Arbeitssuchende die ja kommen soll wie
die genau ausgestaltet wird der nächste